ich rufe nun auf den einzelplan 25 und
das ist der erfüllt das ministerium für
wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen wie
sie alle wissen ein neu formiertes
ministerium bis 20 21 war der bereich
bau ja teil des
bundesinnenministeriums jetzt also in
eigenverantwortung bei klara geywitz aus
der spd und eines der großen ziele
dieses ministerium es ist es insgesamt
das insgesamt fünf milliarden euro zur
verfügung haben wird in diesem jahr der
bau von 400.000 neuen wohnungen im jahr
davon 100.000 öffentlich gefördert das
wird schwierig werden sagen experten
wobei es in erster linie nicht am geld
liegt sondern daran dass ist ein
material fehlt mir aber noch an
fachkräften die das ganze machen so ein
markus uhl für die unionsfraktion ist
der erste redner
kolleginnen und kollegen und im
beratungen des einzel plans 25 des
bundesministeriums hier wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen hatten wir
ja eine besonderheit nämlich dass wir
einen haushalt eines neuen ministeriums
zu beraten hatten zum ersten mal seit
1998 gibt es wieder ein eigenständiges
wohnen beziehungsweise bauministerium
und ein eigenes haus ein neues haus ist
natürlich mit allerlei herausforderungen
verbunden da hakt ist
verständlicherweise an der ein oder
anderen stelle noch dennoch möchte ich
als hauptberichterstatter dem haus den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern sowie
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
für den konstruktiven austausch und die
beratungen dank den ressort stehen knapp
fünf milliarden euro zur verfügung größe
ausgabe mit einer milliarde euro ist das
baukindergeld das ja die alte cdu
geführte bundesregierung eingeführt hat
meine damen und herren vor den
hintergrund steigender immobilienpreise
ist die schaffung von bezahlbarem
wohnraum eine der größten
herausforderung unserer zeit die
stärkung der wohneigentumsbildung und
insbesondere für haushalte mit kindern
ist neben den mietwohnungsbau ein
zentrales instrument und dabei ist klar
die eigenen vier wände sind und bleiben
eine krisenfeste wertanlage und ein
wichtiger bestandteil auch der
persönlichen altersvorsorge
das baukindergeld dass die alte
bundesregierung eingeführt hat ist ein
erfolgs wurde und deshalb geht es auch
darum jetzt zuschauen wie es in zukunft
weitergehen kann das baukindergeld
trifft aus nach willen der ampel soll es
ja auch ein jahr früher auslaufen als
bislang geplant und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass klarheit darüber herrscht
wie das thema wohneigentumsbildung in
zukunft vorangebracht werden soll und
wir haben als union in der
bereinigungssitzung maßgabe beschluss
vorgelegt der an das erfolgreiche
baukindergeld anknüpft und insbesondere
junge familien beim erwerb ihrer ersten
immobilie unterstützt dem sind sie
leider nicht gefolgt aber
immerhin sie haben sich dazu
durchgerungen die bundesregierung
aufzufordern zeit mal ein konzept zur
förderung des erwerbs von wohneigentum
vorzunehmen vorzulegen darum ganz
ehrlich ist es dann auch im bereich der
städtebauförderung gelaufen nachdem die
neue bundesregierung im gegensatz zum
alten entwurf die mittel für die
fortführung des förderprogramms
investitionen in nationale projekte des
städtebaus gestrichen hatte und damit
das bereits begonnene auswahlverfahren
für 2022 abgebrochen werden musste haben
wir in den haushaltsberatungen den
antrag gestellt ein neues förderprogramm
für dieses jahr aufzulegen dem ist die
koalition nun auch in der
bereinigungssitzung gefolgt und damit
ist es möglich dass der bund auch in
zukunft herausragende projekte des
städtebaus und der barkultur mit
besonderer nationaler aber auch
internationaler wahrnehmbarkeit einen
hohen innovationspotenzial fördert
und ja zum dritten genau so gelaufen ist
es dann auch bei dem mit programm
altersgerecht umbauen
damit fördert seit 2009 sehr erfolgreich
bauliche maßnahmen in wohngebäuden mit
denen barrieren reduziert wird davon
profitieren alle altersgruppen um
insbesondere ältere menschen wird der
längere verbleibenden altere wird der
längeren verbleib den älteren in den
eigenen vier wänden ermöglicht uns für
22 waren zunächst keine neuen mittel
mehr vorgesehen und nachdem wir einen
entsprechenden antrag gestellt haben ist
die ampel dann mit einem eigenen antrag
gekommen wenn auch in geringeren volumen
da aber die mittel häufig vor ablauf des
haushaltsjahres aufgebraucht sind wäre
natürlich ein höherer ansatz hilfreich
gewesen gut nach dem motto gut gedacht
aber schlecht gemacht meine damen und
herren sie sehen damit opposition wird
unsere anträge waren vorbild und sie
waren darüber hinaus auch noch alle
gegenfinanziert
ich fasse zusammen die änderungen der
ampel am ursprünglichen regierungs und
wo vom vergangenen jahr sind
überschaubar in einigen punkten ist die
ampel unseren vorschlägen gefolgt
insgesamt setzten sie falsche
schwerpunkte sie kürzen sehr
erfolgreichen förderprogramme wie das
zum einbruchschutz unterlassen andere
früher auslaufen sie bleiben hinter den
selbst gesteckten erwartungen ihres
koalitionsvertrags zurück und sie setzen
die schwerpunkte falsch
1500 stellen sind vom alten
bundesbauministerium im
bundesinnenministerium in das neue haus
und das neue ressort gewechselt hinzu
kommen etwa 100 stellen zum aufbau des
neuen hauses und jetzt gab's im
parlament verfahren noch mal 380 weitere
stellen für das ressort dazu das ist in
der relation gesehen einsamer rekord
aller ressorts im bund dass es fast ein
viertel zusätzliches personal
ja meine damen und herren frau
ministerin mit so viel personal dann
muss es ja klappen mit den
ambitionierten projekten wie zum
beispiel beim wohnungsbau personal
sollte jetzt genügend dasein vielen dank
markus uhl war das aus der
unionsfraktion der erste redner in der
debatte über den etat des ministeriums
höhe wohnen stadtentwicklung und
bauwesen und dessen chefin ist da die
zuständige ministerin klara geywitz auf
dem weg zum rednerpult
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren abgeordnete herum sie haben es
erwähnt das erste mal seit 98 gibt es
wieder ein bauministerium das heißt es
gibt auch das erste mal wieder ein etat
wir haben die wunderbare nummer 25
abbekommen und dieses neu gewordene baby
die etwa 25 der wurde in den
parlamentarischen beratungen von ihnen
vor den berichterstattern vom
haushaltsausschuss noch mal ordentlich
aufgepäppelt dafür meinen herzlichen
dank auch für diese sehr schöne
unterstützung auf dem weg ins leben des
ministeriums das ist nämlich eine
hervorragende grundlage für die
investition in vieles in nachhaltiges
bauen in bezahlbaren wohnraum und ein
gutes leben in stadt und land und wir
investieren in die zukunft unseres
landes denn jeder euro fördermittel
generiert natürlich weitere private und
öffentliche investitionen das neue
bauministerium ist also vor allem einen
investitions ministerium in die zukunft
der gesellschaft wir setzen impulse für
eine gute konjunktur und für einen
stabilen arbeitsmarkt in deutschland
der bau bietet eine große zahl von
beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten für
fachkräfte in vielen berufszweigen
und wir haben sicherheit geschaffen die
finanzplanung die reicht bis 2025 und
sie zeigt wir sind verlässlicher partner
herzlichen dank auf einen
parlamentarierinnen und parlamentariern
herr uhl hat es bewegt es war ein
ungewöhnliches startbedingungen für die
haushaltsberatungen mein haus hat
versucht ihre arbeit so gut es geht zu
unterstützen
eines unserer hauptziele ist es mehr
wohnraum zu schaffen vor allem solchen
den sich alle menschen leisten können
herr uhl ist nicht darauf eingegangen
aber einer der großen schwerpunkte ist
dass wir es geschafft haben die mittel
des sozialen wohnungsbaus des
wohnungsbaus deutlich zu stärken bis
2026 werden 14,5 milliarden fließen in
den sozialen wohnungsbau
das ist ein großer beitrag auch um die
knappheit von bezahlbaren wohnraum in
den ballungsgebieten zu entspannen
wir sorgen dafür auch mit mitteln durch
für alters- und barriere gerechtes
umbauen dass menschen länger an ihren
vier wänden bleiben können und die
haushaltsberatungen haben einen akzent
gesetzt auf den erwerb von
genossenschaftsanteilen
hier ist es im parlamentarischen
verfahren möglich gewesen sechs
millionen euro für diesen wichtigen
bereich einzustellen ich bin sicher dass
wir damit einen deutlichen impuls setzen
wir an für gründung und neue impulse und
wir haben ja uns im ausschuss
verständigt dass diese bundesregierung
auch eine konzeption für die
eigentumsförderung für den nächsten
haushalt vorlegen wird doch allein geld
baut natürlich keine häuser auch
ministerialbeamte machen das in der
regel nicht wir sind darauf angewiesen
in einem breiten bündnis mit den
akteuren aus bund ländern und kommunen
der bauwirtschaft den gewerkschaften und
der zivilgesellschaft die
rahmenbedingungen zu setzen dass in
deutschland wieder mehr gebaut werden
kann und sie haben die zahlen gehört im
letzten jahr von bauminister seehofer
sind die zahlen nach unten gegangen über
300.000 unter 300.000 wohnungen sind
fertig geworden gleichzeitig haben wir
88 47.000 wohnungen in der warteschlange
überhang wir müssen also insgesamt
also die herren müssen sich da gar nicht
aufregen zahlen sind erst mal zahlen und
zu meiner auch gar nicht schön
überraschungen sind die zahlen im
letzten jahr unter 300.000 gewesen bei
gleichzeitig ganz ganz großen zahlen von
wohnungen die schon genehmigt sind die
darauf warten gebaut zu werden und wir
müssen alles tun um die art und weise
wie wir bauen effizienter zu gestalten
damit diese wohnungen dann tatsächlich
auch schnell gebaut werden können dabei
ist ein wichtiger punkt die
transformation wir müssen die
produktivität der bauwirtschaft erhöhen
neben bagger instrument müssen in
zukunft auch software und künstliche
intelligenz ihren platz am bau haben und
wir investieren 10 millionen in wim und
wir werden sämtliche
verwaltungsprozesse im baubereich
digitalisieren das fängt an beim
raumordnungsgesetz den digitalen
planungsverfahren geht über die
einführung der digitalen bauakte bis zur
einführung von digitalen gebäude
zwilling wir haben
angekündigt
dass der bundeskanzler im herbst mit den
ländern einen pakt zur planungs und
genehmigungsbeschluss schließen wird und
mein baum liste haben wird wesentlichen
beitrag dazu leisten dass vor ort
schneller geplant werden kann dass die
kommunen so ausgestattet sind dass die
verfahren so modernisiert werden dass
das passieren kann ein zweiter punkt ist
der wichtige punkt klimaschutz wir
dürfen klimaschutz und wohnungsneubau
nicht gegeneinander ausspielen sondern
wir müssen sehen wie wir mit
nachhaltigen baustoffen wie wir mit
modernen bauformen ist schaffen beides
miteinander zusammen zu bringen und wir
investieren in den zusammenhalt unserer
gesellschaft die 476 millionen euro die
wir zur verfügung haben in diesem jahr
um schwimmbäder um sporthallen um
bolzplätze energetisch zu sanieren
das ist eine große unterstützung für den
sport für die zivilgesellschaft für die
kommunen und für alle menschen die sich
begegnen wollen
die städtebauförderung ist etabliert sie
wird auf hohem niveau von 790 millionen
euro fortgeführt und sie haben es
erwähnt er auch das programm nationale
projekte des städtebaus dass den
abgeordneten des bundestages ganz
besonders am herzen liegt wird mit 75
millionen weitergeführt und wir werden
es auch dieses jahr schaffen die
wichtigen projekte in diesem bereich
auszuführen und zwei punkte sind mir
ganz wichtig das eine ist die frage
barrierefreier umbau von wohngebäuden
das wird ein schwerpunkt sein auch in
den beratungen des bündnisses für
bezahlbares baum ist es doch kein zufall
dass ich gesagt habe ich will dass der
beauftragte der bundesregierung für die
belange von menschen mit behinderung
mitglied im bündnis ist das mit den
agenten mitglied im bündnis ist weil wir
natürlich
einen sehr sehr großen bedarf haben und
wir haben eine sehr zersplitterten
förderlandschaft wir haben das
kfw-darlehen wir haben die kaffee
unterstützung jetzt über diesen haushalt
wir haben einzelne landesprogramme und
ich bin der meinung dass wir diese
mittel auch bündeln müssen um es den
betroffenen so einfach zurück wie
möglich zu machen und ihnen auch die
sicherheit zu geben dass wenn sie ihre
wohnung umgebaut haben dass sie die dann
nicht beim auszug auch wieder
zurückbauen müssen das ist ja vollkommen
unsinnig der zweite punkt die anpassung
der urbanen räume an den klimawandel
auch hier fließen 176 millionen euro
über den etf in die förderung unserer
städte wir merken es die sommer die
werden heißer sie werden trockner und
die städte das grün in den städten ist
unter stress und wir brauchen auch mehr
speicher möglichkeiten für wasser bei
starkregen ereignissen muss es schnell
abfließen können und im sommer muss es
dazu beitragen unsere städte zu kühlen
sehr geehrte damen und herren
transformation ist das stichwort der
heutigen zeit und mit diesem haushalt
beginnen wir auch in der politik eine
neue phase es geht um eine
zukunftsaufgabe nämlich darum die wir
genug bezahlbaren klimagerechten
wohnraum schaffen die wir ein
innovatives bauwesen in deutschland
schaffen wie wir es schaffen können
schwung für die digitalisierung im
gebäudebereich und im quartier zu
schaffen und wie wir gerade nach
bewohner dazu beitragen dass unsere
stadtquartiere und ortskerne lebendig
bleiben oder werden und wir brauchen
eine besondere achtsamkeit für die
älteren und schwächeren in unserer
gesellschaft und ich weiß die kommunen
sind oder starken stress was diese
ganzen transformationen angelangt die
verkehrswende die bau wende die klima
anpassungsmaßnahmen unser ministerium
wird ihnen an ihrer seite stehen der
haushalt den sie beraten haben die
einzelplan 25 den sie aufgepäppelt haben
der ist dafür eine großartige grundlage
herzlichen dank
klarer gallwitz ministerin für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen mit einem
überblick zu den projekten ihres hauses
ihres ministeriums ein punkt natürlich
in diesen zeiten das klimagerechtes
bauen
aber sie wird gemessen werden an den
vorgaben die die bundesregierung selber
gemacht hat 400.000 neue wohnungen pro
jahr davon 100.000 sozial gebunden marc
bernhard ist am pult für die afd und er
ist sprecher für bauen und wohnen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
frau ministerin gail witz sie wollen co2
emissionen von gebäuden bis 20.30
halbieren in gerade mal acht jahren
gleichzeitig haben sie auch gerade eben
gesagt wollen sie bauen
sozialverträglich gestalten beides
zusammen ist schlichtweg unmöglich und
viele menschen werden bei ihren plänen
auf der strecke bleiben die hälfte der
mieter in deutschen großstädten müssen
heute schon mehr als 30 prozent vom
netto für die miete beraten 26 zahlen
über 40 und 12 prozent sogar über 50
prozent fürs wohnen dabei mussten
bereits 2020 über 7,4 millionen menschen
frieren weil sie nicht genug geld fürs
heizen hatten wie viele menschen sollen
unter ihrer regierung denn eigentlich
noch dazukommen ihre klimaziele im
baubereich umzusetzen würde nichts
anderes bedeuten als millionen von
intakten wohnungen abzureißen weil es
auch mit der teuersten sanierung gar
nicht ihrem geplanten
standard er 55 überhaupt erreichen
könnten und bei diesem standard kostet
ein quadratmeter heute schon
3400 euro und das führt zu einer
kaltmiete von mindestens 13 euro 50 und
das können sich heute schon 80 prozent
der menschen gar nicht mehr leisten und
ab 2025 wollen sie ja sogar 40 zum
standard machen und das wird dann
endgültig zu unbezahlbar kite führen das
haben wir auch im übrigen heute morgen
in der anhörung gehört für das fehlen
von 2.000.000 bezahlbaren wohnungen
machen sie lieferengpässe
rohstoffknappheit und preissteigerungen
verantwortlich kommen aber nicht auf die
idee dass ihre gesetze verordnungen
steuern und abgaben des bauen extrem
verteuern und in immer neue höhen
treiben also frau ministerin sie können
sich entweder an ihren völlig
unrealistischen plänen festhalten die
menschen frieren lassen und wohnen zum
luxus machen oder endlich für bezahlbare
warme wohnungen sorgen
aber was machen sie was machen sie in
diesem haushalt
luxusprojekte fördern beispielsweise
eine kita im kanzleramt kosten 28
millionen euro für sage und schreibe
zwölf bis 15 kinder für das gleiche geld
werden sonst überall im land kitas für
80 kinder gebaut damit kosten diese
luxus kita-plätze fünfmal so viel wie
für die normalen menschen da draußen
geldverschwendung ist auch ihr programm
bimaq sie fordern damit zb videos der
volkshochschule coburg in denen gezeigt
wird wie man pfannen brötchen backt oder
in nürnberg ein videoprojekt erwerbs
integration das in eineinhalb jahren
sage und schreibe ganze 16 mal
aufgerufen wurde
welch ein irrwitz frau gallwitz an
diesem beispiel sieht man wo die
prioritäten dieser regierung lieben
frau ministerin ihre erste und
wichtigste aufgabe muss es doch sein für
ausreichend bezahlbare und warme
wohnungen zu sorgen und nicht das geld
der bürger für luxusprojekte oder
nonsens programme wie biwak auszugeben
damit wohnen in deutschland endlich
wieder für jeden bezahlbar wird fordern
wir die senkung der grunderwerbsteuer
die abschaffung der grundsteuer und die
streichung aller
kostentreibenden bauvorschriften
und frau ministerin ich bitte sie fanden
brötchen backen gehört wirklich nicht zu
den aufgaben ihres ministeriums
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun der kollege andreas angriff das
wurde
entschuldigung aber
das ist hier nicht zu entziffern gewesen
dennoch sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren wohnen ist
ein grundbedürfnis und wohnen ist auch
ein grundrecht wohnraum darf kein
luxusgut sein und in vielen städten in
deutschland sehen wir leider dass es
dennoch genauso ist manche menschen
stehen
stundenlang an an wohnungen immer in der
angst keine zu bekommen immer in der
angst die wohnung die sie brauchen nicht
zu bekommen oder aus der alten wohnung
rauszufliegen sich für ein iphone
anzustellen oder für andere luxusgüter
dass es in ordnung bei wohnungen dürfen
wir das niemals akzeptieren
bundes eine der ganz großen sozialen
fragen unserer zeit und von wohnungen
hält hängt so viel ab und deswegen es
ist richtig dass diese bundesregierung
ein neues ministerium geschaffen hat
diese koalition ein neues ministerium
geschaffen hat dass sich diesen
herausforderungen ganz speziell widmet
und dafür einen eigenen etat zur
verfügung hat die ministerin hat das
eingehend ausgeführt und das ist auch
richtig dass wir in diesem etat einen
ganz großen teil des geldes für den
sozialen wohnungsbau ausgeben bis 2026
14,5 milliarden euro das ist mehr als
das dreifache
die ursprünglich in der finanzplanung
vorgesehen war und das ist gut so und
das ist richtig so
denn
wohnraum zu schaffen wohnraum zu
schaffen ist auch eine staatliche
aufgabe es rächt sich jetzt und wir
sehen jetzt wie es sich recht dass der
staat sich in den letzten jahren immer
mehr aus der wohnungspolitik
zurückgezogen hatte der schwund an
sozialwohnungen ist ein ernstzunehmendes
problem überall in deutschland und wir
werden das mit der politik die wir jetzt
von seiten der ampel machen aufhalten
und zurückdrängen wir schaffen einen
zweiten einen doppelten boden auf dem
wohnungsmarkt und weil wir eine echte
wende wollen und weil wir sozialen
wohnungsbau auch klima gerecht machen
wollen geben wir natürlich auch geld für
das klimagerechte wohnen und bauen aus
und verbinden so dass soziale und die
klimafrage in der politik bei uns
hunderttausend sozialwohnungen jährlich
das ist eine menge holz aber wir wissen
dass das am ende nicht ausreichend wird
und deswegen freue ich mich so dass wir
mit dem haushalt
2022 auch endlich das kfw programm zur
förderung von genossenschaftsanteilen
staaten konnten millionen menschen in
deutschland schließen sich zusammen sie
planen gemeinsam geschaffen wohnraum
gemeinsam aber sie schaffen noch viel
mehr sie schaffen dauerhaft günstigen
wohnraum stellen den zur verfügung und
probieren gleichzeitig ganz viele neue
wohnformen aus übernehmen verantwortung
füreinander weit über die kernfamilie
hinaus und das ist an der stelle nicht
nur der start eines weiteren
kfw-programms dass es gleichzeitig auch
das zeichen dieser koalition dass
genossenschaften die eigenheime der
zukunft sind und dass wir gleichermaßen
die verantwortungsübernahme für einander
in dieser gesellschaft fördern
das geschafft ist ein erster schritt wir
wollen aber weiter wir wollen auch im
haushalt 2023 weiterkommen und daran
anknüpfen die neue wohngebiet wohnen
gemeinnützigkeit steht im
koalitionsvertrag und muss kommen denn
sie schafft dauerhaft
günstigen wohnraum und alle die bereit
sind in der gesellschaft verantwortung
zu übernehmen sollen dann auch
profitieren können genau darum geht es
es geht nicht um start auf der einen
seite und privat auf der anderen seite
oder einen gegeneinander dieser beiden
dieser beiden richtungen sondern es geht
um die frage wer bereit ist in der
gesellschaft verantwortung zu übernehmen
und sich an kriterien zu halten und
soziales und ökologisches wohnen auf den
weg zu bringen das ist die maxime der
politik und deswegen werden wir die
wohnen gemeinnützigkeit mit den nächsten
jahren einführen
zu hause muss sicherheit bieten und ein
zuhause muss geborgenheit bieten beides
geht verloren wenn heizkosten
explodierenden und menschen sich nicht
mehr sicher sein können ob sie das
finanzieren können mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss haben wir deswegen
hier kurzfristig für abhilfe gesorgt 270
euro die direkt bei denen ankommen die
diese unterstützung auch tatsächlich
brauchen das ist gut und gleichzeitig
ist klar dass wir lösungen auch für den
nächsten winter finden müssen wir
erleben dass gaspreise ein zentraler
treiber der inflation sind dass die
gaspreise gleichzeitig von diktator
wladimir putin dazu genutzt werden um
sie als kriegswaffe auch einzusetzen und
um gesellschaften zu spalten und mit
blick auf dem nächsten auf den nächsten
winter steht deswegen für uns auch im
mittelpunkt niemand in deutschland darf
in einer kalten wohnung sitzen jede und
jeder hier in deutschland hat ein recht
auf ein warmes zuhause und das werden
wir gemeinsam erfüllen
wohnungen der zukunft müssen mehr
leisten wohnungen der zukunft müssen so
gebaut oder saniert sein dass sie für
alle zugänglich sind auch für menschen
mit behinderung auch für ältere menschen
und so schwer die situation auf dem
wohnungsmarkt für ganz ganz viele
menschen ist desto mehr wissen wir wie
schwer es ist wenn menschen zum beispiel
im rollstuhl sitzen und eine wohnung
suchen der anteil an barrierearmen oder
barrierefreien wohnungen ist immer noch
viel zu klein und deswegen haben wir
hier im bundestag in den beratungen
gesagt dass wir das
programm altersgerecht umbauen nicht
auslaufen lassen wollen sondern dass wir
wollen dass dieses programm
weitergeführt wird und haben dafür ganz
dezidiert mittel eingestellt
weil väter nicht nur um das sanieren von
wohnungen in einer alternden
gesellschaft und in einer gesellschaft
wo der demografische wandel so eine
große rolle spielt ist die frage ob es
finanzierbar ist ob man das badezimmer
umbauen kann eine frage von
selbstbestimmtheit und auch eine frage
von freiheit und insofern investieren
wir gerade in einer alternden
gesellschaft hier auch in freiheit und
selbstbestimmung von menschen
die wohnung ist das eine darüber habe
ich viel gesprochen wie wir an der
stelle politik man aber das wohnumfeld
ist das zweite und auch das ist
adressiert in diesem etat wir wollen die
ganzen potenziale unserer innenstädte
und ortskerne heben und haben genau das
mit geld in dem etat hinterlegt darum
haben wir auch wiederum hier im
bundestag in den haushaltsberatungen
mittel bereitgestellt um das programm
nationale projekte des städtebaus
fortzuführen weil es uns ein anliegen
war genau das hier voran zu bringen und
wir müssen jeden euro so investieren
dass wir künftig auf nachhaltigkeit
setzen und die und so auch auf die
zukunft vorbereiten und dafür warten
deswegen wird das programm zur sanierung
kommunaler einrichtungen ab jetzt auch
zur energetischen sanierung genutzt es
ist nur konsequent dass wir das programm
künftig aus dem klima- und
transformations- fonds finanzieren denn
wir bekämpfen klimakrise künftig auch
beim umbau von sportstätten oder auch
bei gebäuden in der jugend und
kulturarbeit
wir haben die beratungen genutzt um den
entwurf der bundesregierung hier im
bundestag besser zu machen und wir
bereiten uns damit auch vor auf die
nächsten jahre werden daran anknüpfen
und gemeinsam auch dann die wende
herbeiführen und das ganze sozial und
ökologisch nachhaltig gestalten danken
für die fraktion die linke hat nun die
kollegin caren lay das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren die bundesregierung
auch vor allen dingen eines
luftschlösser
beginnen wir mit den angekündigten
400.000 wohnungen pro jahr nur etwa
290.000 wohnungen wurden im letzten jahr
fertig gestellt das sind 4,2 prozent
weniger als vor einem jahr sie scheitern
an den eigenen selbst gesteckten zielen
dabei waren sie es die in bauen bauen
bauen das allheilmittel für den
wohnungsmarkt für die wohnungskrise
gesehen haben wie jetzt linke haben
immer gesagt es kommt darauf an was
gebaut wird aber gerade beim sozialen
wohnungsbau können sie uns nicht sagen
wie die versprochenen 100.000
sozialwohnungen pro jahr finanziert ich
habe die bundesregierung in fragt welche
berechnung der hinterlegt antwort es
gibt keine berechnung sie versprechen
hunderttausend sozialwohnung jahr und
können nicht sagen wir es finanzieren
wollen das ist ja wohl absurd
und da es keine kalkulation geliefert
wird können wir gemeinsam überschlagen
14,5 milliarden euro sollen ausgegeben
haben also eine verdreifachung der
mittel ungefähr das ist gut gerade weil
ich an dieser stelle sehr lange auch
vergeblich für eine erhöhung der mittel
für den sozialen wohnungsbau gekämpft
habe aber mit einer verdreifachung der
mittel mehr als eine vervierfachung der
sozialwohnungen zu finanzieren bei
gestiegenen kosten als entschuldigung
dass es einfach umständen
markus lässt sich die ministerin in die
karten der magischen rechnung schauen
und sehen darf die länder sollen mehr
finanzieren sie seien ja eigentlich
zuständig aber ich will daran erinnern
wir haben hier gemeinsam das grundgesetz
geändert gerade weil der bund wieder in
die verantwortung für den sozialen
wohnungsbau gehen sollte schon alleine
deswegen können wir ihnen nicht
durchgehen lassen die schuld bei den
ländern abzuladen das lassen wir ihnen
nicht durchgehen
das ziel 100000 sozialwohnungen zu bauen
das ist richtig aber stellen sie das
geld bereit staates und rüstung zu
versenken
meine anfrage zur bundessache immobilien
anstalt bühne brachten auch wenig
rühmliches zutage die bima hatte im
letzten jahr sage und schreibe sechs
wohnungen gebaut sie lassen wohnungen in
größenordnung her stehen das ist einfach
nur peinlich
die neue woche gemeinnützigkeit muss
kommen ja genau das sehen wir als linke
genauso aber wo ist sie denn ich meine
es geht doch darum eine nicht
profitorientierte sektor auf dem
wohnungsmarkt aufzubauen das muss so
schnell wie möglich kommen das muss
möglich sein das darf nicht länger auf
sich warten
deswegen müsste vom ersten tag an jeder
euro den wir ausgeben im bau haushalt in
den aufbau dieser neuen wohnungs
gemeinnützigkeit fließen anstatt weiter
wohnungskonzern mit millionenbeträgen zu
subventionieren die am ende dann das
geld als dividende an die aktionäre
ausschütten das ist absurd ihnen solche
der vorderhand zugedreht werden
wir müssen doch wie wertig städte und
gemeinden unterstützen dass sie mehr
bauen bau wie in green das ist unsere
lösung kaufen wir uns die stadt zurück
das ist unsere losung
für uns enke ist klar wohnen muss
bezahlbar sein wir wollen mehr als 20
milliarden euro jährlich mehr
investieren 15 milliarden im jahr für
sozialen kommunalen und gemeinnützigen
wohnungsbau und tagesprogramm es muss
eben auch ein ankaufprogramm seien für
sozialwohnungen für belegungsrechte für
rekommunalisierung damit sich auch
menschen mit kleinem geldbeutel endlich
wieder eine wohnung leisten können
wir brauchen einen bogen fenster mit
bauland wieder bezahlbar wird und ein
klimagerechtes sanierungsprogramm in
höhe von 5 milliarden euro im jahr den
klimaschutz muss auch ohne mieterhöhung
möglich sein
von qsc ag hat in berlin einen
unausgegorenen vorschlag präsentiert
nicht mehr jeder soll nicht mehr als 30
prozent des einkommens für das wohnen
ausgeben das ist richtig aber als
allgemeine forderung ist es wenig
handhabbar wir haben einen vorschlag
gemacht beim umwelt konnte man das
konkret mit diesem haushalt beschließen
das ist unser vorschlag als linke und
zu guter letzt es hat natürlich nicht
alles mit geld zu tun man könnte auch
einfach gute gesetze machen wir
bräuchten einen bundesweiten mieten
deckel oder wenigstens fünf jahre
mädchens doch und das hat ja die spd im
rat haben auch vollmundig versprochen
aber jetzt ist doch nichts davon übrigen
koalitionsvertrag ein wort dafür noch
nichtmals das vorkaufsrecht kriegen sie
ja geändert obwohl es sich um einen
einzigen paragrafen handelt also in der
letzten legislatur hieß es immer die spd
kann sich als kleiner koalitionspartner
nicht gegen die cdu durchsetzen jetzt
stellt sie den kanzler sie stellen die
ministerin sie haben mit den grünen
zusammen eine mehrheit in dieser
koalition
jetzt können sie nicht gegen die fdp
durchsetzen also säure genossen und da
stimmt was nicht
also kosten sich ein heraufsetzen video
wahlversprechen durch das monopoly muss
beendet werden
keinerlei vergleicht die wohnungspolitik
mit einem monopoly spiel jedenfalls am
ende ihrer rede karin da ist ja
sprecherin für mieten bau und
wohnungspolitik hier geht es weiter um
den etat des bundesbauministeriums unter
spricht jetzt etwas mehr herz aus der
fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wir diskutieren heute
über einen besonderen einzelplan
besonders der einzelplan eines neuen
ministeriums ist und besonders auch weil
wir hier bereits das bauministerium der
höchste investitionsquote in allen
haushaltsplänen haben und das ist halt
positiv auf die investitionsquote des
bundeshaushalt ist ein wichtiges unserer
sicht wird durch mich nur kommt
konsumieren wir müssen investieren und
das tun wir mit diesem haushalt
die aufgaben im bereich des
bauministeriums sind zweifellos groß es
geht darum wohnen bezahlbar zu gestalten
bauinvestitionen zu unterstützen bremsen
zu lösen es geht darum eigentumsbildung
zu ermöglichen und es geht darum die
stadtentwicklung weiter voranzutreiben
das ist vor dem aktuellen umfeld alles
nicht trivial das ist völlig klar aber
wir sind als koalition entschlossen
diese herausforderung anzugehen ich bin
überzeugt dass neue bauministerium wird
mit uns gemeinsam in dieser koalition
die richtigen akzente setzen
ein haushalt von rund fünf milliarden
das klingt auf den ersten blick recht
viel das klingt nach viel
gestaltungsspielraum aber zur wahrheit
gehört auch dass das vorgänger
ministerium was csu geführt war unser
fehler verpflichtungen hinterlassen hat
programme die wir jetzt finanzieren
müssen und die unseren
gestaltungsspielräume einengen danach
konnten wir neue akzente setzen ich
möchte zwei hier erwähnen das programm
altersgerecht umbauen das bekommt jetzt
frisches geld weil wir älteren menschen
ermöglichen wollen länger in den eigenen
vier wänden zu leben das ist
selbstbestimmtes leben und es ist nicht
nur eine wohnungspolitische sondern auch
eine soziale frage meine damen und
herren
und wir können zudem neue bundesmittel
für kommunale investitionsprojekte
mobilisieren stehe jetzt 400 millionen
euro zur verfügung für die sanierung von
sport kultur
freizeiteinrichtungen wer die situation
kennt wir alle sehen dass in unseren
wahlkreisen dass es dringend benötigt
das geld das ist gut angelegtes geld
die zwischenrufe aus der csu natürlich
gab es die forschung aber wenn wir nicht
frisches geld investieren würden ja kein
euro verfügbar um mit neue projekte
anzugehen
und meine damen und herren ich freue
mich auch dass es gelungen ist dass wir
jetzt einen anstoß geben ein neues
programm zur förderung von privaten
wohneigentums
vorzulegen bis oktober das förderkonzept
gearbeitet und ich sage immer mehr
sozialer wohnungsbau und mehr privates
wohneigentum das sind keine gegensätze
wir brauchen beides in unserem land
und übrigens beide bereiche haben ja die
gleichen herausforderung wir sehen
steigende baukosten engpässe bei
fachkräften bei baumaterial
aufsteigender bau zins und es deshalb
eine herausforderung war ja wohl nicht
irgendein luxus ist wohnen ist ein
existenzielles bedürfnis und nicht nur
wohnen sondern auch das wohneigentum ist
ein existenzielles bedürfnis und wir
sehen es ja als aufgabe an einer
gesellschaft dass wir das
aufstiegsversprechen auch damit umsetzen
dass jemand der hart arbeitet sie etwas
zurück legt dass der sich privates
wohneigentum leisten kann der traum vom
wohneigentum darf nicht zum
unerreichbaren ziel wäre
in diesem zusammenhang anders als die
linke das darstellt es sind ja nicht
alle vermieter diese gierigen großen
konzerne die vermeintlich gierig sind
über über 60 prozent aller vermieteten
wohnung in diesem land gehören kleinen
kleinst vermieden wir haben manchmal
eine manchmal zwei wohnungen und ohne
die an engagement auf dem wohnungsmarkt
in deutschland ganz anders aus
die fachkräftesituation im baubereich
die bleibt anstrengend und das baustoff
thema mit sicherheit auch deshalb geht
es auch darum dass er
produktivität und innovation fördern
denn wir kommen nur aus dem dilemma
heraus wenn wir effizienter bauen und
ich dich wurde sind digitalisierung
seiles bauern baustoff forschung nur
durch innovation machen wir das bauen
effizienter und wir müssen effizienter
machen
wenn wir sehen ja auch ihr teure wir
bauen desto teurer werden natürlich die
mieten und deshalb müssen wir alles
dafür tun dass die kosten nicht
unendlich steigen wenn schon am markt
die kosten deutlich steigen dann darf
das starten und nach dem kostentreiber
werden das ist unsere gemeinsame
verantwortung hier in diesem haus
als koalition wollen wir die
voraussetzung geschaffen dass wieder
mehr gebaut werden kann daß
genehmigungen vereinfacht werden dass
die bohnen raum bezahlbar bleibt dass
ich mehr menschen den traum vom
wohneigentum erfüllen dass unser
anspruch den wir als koalition haben und
ich bedanke mich ausdrücklich bei man
mit berichterstattern in der koalition
ich bedanke mich beim bauministerium die
großes geleistet haben bei der
haushaltsaufstellung trotz eines
ministeriums was sich im aufbau befindet
und ich bedanke mich auch bei den
berichterstattenden koalition es waren
insgesamt sehr konstruktive sehr faire
verhandlungen meine damen und herren wir
haben jetzt erste weichen für eine
moderne innovative politik gestellt
weitere werden mit dem haushalt 2023
folgen vielen dank
torsten herbst für die fdp-fraktion und
beim thema wohnen zum thema wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen jetzt er
mit tollen da aus der unionsfraktion und
präzise zu sein aus der csu landesgruppe
in diesem haushalt ist gar nichts von
innovationen zu spüren und zu lesen und
zu sehen keine reale boni für
nachhaltiges bauen kein krieg lasterbalk
eine digitalisierung als im nachhinein
wurde da entsprechend nachgesteuert das
können wir als union so nicht stehen
lassen dass sie angeblich die
fortschritts koalition sind im bau
haushalt ist davon nichts zu sehen
wir als union haben uns gefreut dass ein
neues bauministerium entstehen sollte
wir waren neugierig auf die umsetzung da
es dem wichtigen thema wohnen mehr
gewicht verleiht dafür können die
menschen in unserem land aber auch zu
recht etwas erwarten nämlich dass
politik dann auch liefert dieses
ministerium muss den unterschied machen
aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt müsste das
bauministerium er zum baustopp
ministerium umbenannt werden ein
mehrwert ist nicht erkennbar
zukunftsträchtige konzepte fehlanzeige
die fährte fertigstellen neuer wohnungen
geht im vergleich zum letzten jahr die
kollegin mey hat angesprochen sogar
zurück das ziel der bundesregierung
400.000 die wohnungen zu bauen rückt in
weite ferne dafür können sich die ampel
regierung als personalaufbau koalition
aber 10.000 neue stellen das ist sicher
aber ob die ampel in der lage ist in
gleicher geschwindigkeit 10.000 neue
wohnungen zu organisieren das wage ich
zu bezweifeln
die spd hat sich einfach schon zu beginn
der ampelkoalition verzockt viel zu spät
haben sie ihre ministerin berufen die
bundesanstalt für immobilienaufgaben
ging an das finanzministerium und die
themen kfw-förderung und energetische
sanierung von gebäuden liegt beim
wirtschaftsministerium da ist es auch
nur folgerichtig dass diese beiden
schlüssel ministerium ministerien fürs
bauen erst gar nicht zum von ministerin
gates initiiert bündnis bezahlbarer
wohnraum eingeladen waren dabei muss man
sich schon die frage stellen ob die
bauministerin und der
wirtschaftsminister bambach beim bauen
überhaupt an einem strang ziehen die
eine will kosten günstig bauen der
antrieb schraubt die anforderungen zur
energetischen gebäudesanierung hoch und
im ergebnis verursacht man einen
zweimaligen kfw förderstopp und lässt
damit familien städte und gemeinden und
alle bauwilligen im stich ja durchaus
für nachhaltiges bauen offen sind dabei
sind die
grundvoraussetzungen für investitionen
in wohnraum egal ob in kommunale im
privater gemeinnütziger verantwortung
immer an verlässlichkeit und
berechenbarkeit
gekoppelt denn alle müssen egal in
welchen haushalten verlässlich
kalkulieren können
und da frage ich mich schon
groß sind die glaubhaften konzepte zur
klimaneutralität bei der
gebäudesanierung in denen sie
beschreiben wie dieser finanziert und
diese b realisiert werden sollen wo ist
die steuerliche abschreibung liebe
kollegen von der fdp
dem die erhöht werden soll von zwei auf
drei prozent wo ist die auskömmliche
finanzierung für den altersgerechten
umbau der immens wichtig ist in einer
der ältesten gesellschaft dieser welt wo
sind die konzepte zur eigentumsförderung
überall nur dienst nach vorschrift oder
sie sind komplett blank das
baukindergeld beispielsweise können sie
natürlich schlecht finden wenn sie
meinen das ist der ansatz fakt ist aber
gerade das schwellen haushalte davon
massiv profitiert haben auch
die soziale wohnraumförderung wird wie
schon in der letzten regierung
vorgesehen aufgestockt aber auch das ist
nicht auskömmlich um ihr selbst
gestecktes ziel von 100.000 neuen
sozialwohnungen erreichen zu können
sogar an die städtebaumittel wollten sie
ran und dankenswerterweise haben es die
kollegen in den haushalts bereinigungen
noch verhindert hindern können dieser
haushalt ist wenig zukunftsweisend aber
gerade hier gilt auch das vertrauen in
der politik die summe der gehaltenen
versprechen ist und daran werden wir sie
auf messen vielen dank
die zöllner war das aus der
unionsfraktion in dieser debatte über
den etat des bundes warum ministeriums
und jetzt ist uwe schmidt am rednerpult
aus der spd-fraktion einer der wenigen
handwerker kfz-mechaniker und hafen
facharbeiter hat er mal gelernt
das herzstück ihrer politik ist die
schaffung von bezahlbarem wohnraum als
nationale aufgabe habe jeden ihrer rede
entnommen der bund unterstützt die
länder dabei mit erheblichen mitteln
weil auch die länder sind dafür
zuständig wohnung zu bauen insgesamt
14,5 milliarden euro sind für den
sozialen und klimagerechten wohnungsbau
bis 20 26 in diesem haushalt eingeplant
unmittelbar nach inkrafttreten dieses
bundeshaushalt ist können die länder
bereits über zwei milliarden euro
verfügen und die länder liegen
ihrerseits mindestens noch 30 prozent
der bundesmittel obendrauf denn weder
nämlich auf hat im parlamentarischen
verfahren habe den haushaltsentwurf noch
besser gemacht und mit zusätzlichen
mitteln zielgerecht verstärkt einige
punkte möchte ich dabei noch mal heraus
greifen die wesentlichen ziele im
koalitionsvertrag an meine beiden
vorrednern außerhalb wieder schon
genannt wohneigentum darf kein luxus für
besserverdienende sein wir stellen daher
6 millionen euro zum erwerb von
genossenschaftsanteilen für selbst
genutzten wohnraum zur verfügung damit
ermöglichen wir es künftig jungen
familien mit durchschnittlichen
einkommen wohneigentum zu erwerben
die ampel hat jung und alt gleichermaßen
im blick wir standen das kfw programm
zumal das gerechten umbau von
wohngebäuden mit zusätzlich 75 millionen
euro ja das reicht immer nicht bei den
14 ländern zu wenig mit den mitteln
fördern wir den barriere am umbau von
wohnungen außenbereichen so ermöglichen
wir einen höheren wohnkomfort im alter
in unserer immer älter werdenden
bevölkerung ist dies auch dringend
notwendig hatte die ministerin eben auch
schon angedeutet auch der städtebau
steht vor großen herausforderungen steht
gewachsen immer schneller wohnraum
wieder mal knapper und die luft in den
großstädten immer schlechter auch die
stadt entwicklungen muss auf den
klimawandel reagieren um weitere
vorbilder für projekte der nachhaltigen
stadtentwicklung und des städtebaus in
ganz deutschland zu schaffen
haben wir die mittel für die nationalen
projekte des städtebaus um weitere 75
millionen euro erhöht
unsere städte und kommunen reagieren auf
die vielfältigen städtebaulichen
herausforderungen mit innovativen
konzepten wie das gewächshaus auf dem
dach die vernetzung von kunst und
grünflächen im quartier oder andere
städtebauliche innovation zur lösung
drängender zukunftsaufgaben wie steht
ihr dazu kommen sind nachhaltig
klimaneutral grün und vernetzt in diesem
haushalt haben wir noch zwei weitere
programme für die stadtentwicklung im
bauministerium die dort bewirtschaftet
werden implantieren in den beratungen
ist es uns gelungen das erfolgreiche
programm sanierung kommunaler
einrichtungen in sport jugend und kultur
neu aufzulegen insgesamt 476 millionen
euro stehen in den nächsten jahren für
neue projekte bereit
wir unterstützen damit die städte und
gemeinden bei zahlreichen
sanierungsprojekten und erhalten damit
wichtige soziale infrastruktur vor ort
ob der sportverein um die ecke der
jugendclub in der nachbarschaft oder die
kulturstätten sie alle leisten
tagtäglich einen großartigen beitrag für
den gesellschaftlichen zusammenarbeit
zusammenhalt und die soziale integration
in unserem land aspekte des
klimaschutzes werden künftig auch hier
eine größere rolle bei den
förderkriterien spielen so denkt wir
klimaschutz und sanierungen zusammen und
sorgen für sicherheit im wandel für das
sonderprogramm anpassung urbaner räume
an den klimawandel haben wir die mittel
ebenfalls um 176 millionen euro erhöht
insgesamt stehen 375 millionen euro
bereit damit die kommunen öffentliche
parks und gärten klimafreundlich
weiterentwickeln können städtisches grün
trägt erheblich zur reduktion der
treibhausgasemissionen bei kommunen wird
so ein aktiver beitrag zum klimaschutz
ermöglicht all das in
zukunftsinvestitionen in das bezahlbare
wohnen die nachhaltige stadtentwicklung
und das klimafreundliche baum mein dank
geht an unsere bundesministerin klara
geywitz vielen dank an meine kollegen
andreas auth rich und torsten herbst das
eine produktive zusammenarbeit mit sehr
guten ergebnissen und schließlich gilt
mein dank den vielen mitarbeitenden im
hintergrund in den abgeordnetenbüros und
energierecht schönen dank
das wort hat der abgeordnete markus oehl
für die fdp 10
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
bezahlbares wohnen ist eine der großen
sozialen fragen in dieser zeit inflation
astronomische energiepreise und grüne
auflagen und verbote für haus bauwillige
ziehen unseren bürgern das geld aus der
tasche hinzu kommt die wohnungsknappheit
vor allem in ballungsräumen die unter
anderem durch die völlig gescheiterten
migrationspolitik entstanden ist und
diese politik wird mit der neuen
regierung noch viel schlimmer bauen ist
in deutschland so teuer wie nie die
preise für baumaterial sind enorm hoch
und durch lieferengpässe ist material
knapp das stellt gerade
handwerksbetriebe bei der abgabe von
angeboten vor enorme herausforderungen
ob ihr angebot im laufe des
baufortschritts überhaupt haltbar sein
wird nicht wenige betriebe bringt das in
existenzielle nöte durch die
materialknappheit können vielerorts die
bauzeiten nicht eingehalten werden das
wird in diesem jahr zu einer stagnation
im baugewerbe führen das betrifft nicht
nur die zielerreichung der versprochenen
400.000 wohnungen sondern es betrifft
auch viele familien die sich selbst
gerne ihre eigenen vier wände schaffen
wollten die hohen preise führen dazu
dass die baukosten für diese familien
massiv steigen und damit deren finanzen
ins wanken geraten wir befinden uns in
schweren zeiten es braucht hilfe hilfe
vor allem durch die politik was die
dämpfung von materialpreisen angeht
hilfe aber auch von einer politik die
regeln vereinfacht und diese nicht
weiter verschärft unter dem deckmantel
klimaneutral wird die kostenspirale
durch die links gelbe koalition weiter
hochgetrieben das kann sich unser land
jedoch nicht leisten
[Applaus]
sie würden mit ihren verboten und
auflagen privates bauen grössenordnungen
ab weil es dadurch kaum oder gar nicht
mehr finanzierbar wird frau ministerin
ihr haus steht vor großen aufgaben mit
der einhaltung des gegebenen
versprechens jährlich 400.000 wohnungen
bauen zu wollen und mit dem im
ergänzungs haushalt vorgesehenen
einmaligen zuschuss für heizkosten zum
wohngeld dieses jahr wird es nicht getan
sein dieser einmalige zuschuss ist nur
ein tropfen auf dem heißen stein
hier sind sie und ihre kollegen zum
handeln aufgefordert damit sich viele
bürger im kommenden winter nicht die
frage stellen müssen ob sie entweder
heizen oder etwas zu essen kaufen
wir werden diesem haushalt in dieser
form daher nicht zustimmen ich danke für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
markus mühle war das aus der fdp
fraktion betont materialknappheit hohe
baukosten verbote und auflagen die das
war schwer machen würde personal und
fachkräftemangel erwähnt er nicht anja
liebert ist die nächste rednerin kommt
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
und das mitglied im ausschuss für wohnen
stadtentwicklung
bauwesen und kommunen frau präsidentin
werte kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren die bundesregierung
hatte in den sechs monaten in denen sie
die verantwortung trägt die weichen in
der bau und wohnungspolitik
definitiv neu gestellt und das zentrale
anliegen des hier verhandelten einzel
plans ist die schaffung von zusätzlichem
wohnraum und für uns grüne geht es dabei
darum dass soziale und ökologische
miteinander in einklang zu bringen
und ganz konkret machen wir das ja auch
schon mit der klima milliarde die jetzt
im haushalt
2022 zu finden ist wir fördern
energetisch hochwertigen neubau die
finanzplanung sieht die 14 5 milliarden
euro für den sozialen wohnungsbau vor
und mit dieser sozial gerechten und
ökologischen bau und wohnungspolitik
wollen wir dafür sorgen dass alle
menschen in sicheren bezahlbaren und
klimagerechten wo leben können
und was die cdu uns hinterlassen hat
nämlich das thema auslaufende
fördermittel um was herr altmaier vorher
da eben nicht zu ende gedacht und nicht
zu ende geführt hat das müssen wir jetzt
ausbaden und müssen eben schauen wie wir
das wieder auf einen vernünftigen weg
bringen und das umfeld in der baubranche
ist dafür alles andere als ideal
der wohnungsbau steht unter druck weil
fachkräfte fehlen und die preise für die
baumaterialien kräftig angezogen haben
das hat auch mein vorredner gesagt aber
die frage ist natürlich was ist die
lösung für das problem und die lösung
für das problem bei den fachkräften ist
vor allem zuwanderung
einwanderung mehr menschen in
deutschland in den arbeitsmarkt in
diesem bereich bringen und
qualifizierung der menschen denn alleine
250.000 offene stellen im handwerk und
in den nächsten fünf jahren werden
125.000 kleinere mittlere
handwerksbetriebe eine nachfolge suchen
und dafür brauchen wir eine lösung und
da freuen wir uns natürlich auf menschen
die nach deutschland kommen und hier für
uns in diesem bereich tätig werden
wollen dass die baukosten steigen das
wissen wir und es geht halt darum dass
wir in zukunft konsequent ressourcen
sparen ressourcen schonen und natürlich
auch konsequent aus den fossilen
energieträgern aussteigen und dazu muss
der wohnungssektor einen großen beitrag
leisten und deshalb ist für uns auch die
verschärfung der standards bei der
energetischen sanierung der richtige weg
wir wollen diese verstärkt an
nachhaltigkeit und der co2 einsparung
ausrichten
und wir werden auch in den neuen
haushaltsberatungen 2023 akzente setzen
denn wir haben es natürlich nicht
geschafft in sechs monaten alles
umzusetzen was wir uns vorgenommen haben
der koalitionsvertrag enthält viele
maßnahmen und vorhaben die wir auf den
weg bringen werden unter schwierige
umfeld zwingt uns heute mehr denn je
prioritäten zu setzen und zwar auf
nachverdichtung den schwerpunkt auf
sanierung und umnutzung legen auf
aufstockung und ausbau der schon
vorhandenen bausubstanz und wir müssen
die potenziale des seriellen und
modularen bauens nutzen das bauen
schneller effektiver und preisgünstiger
machen und unsere bau ministerin vor
witz hat ja schon im vorfeld gesagt es
ist nicht sinnvoll und schon gar kein
ökologischer umgang mit knappen
ressourcen noch mehr einfamilienhäuser
auf der grünen wiese außerhalb der
städte zu bauen und deswegen planen wir
die neue wohn gemeinnützigkeit um
dauerhaft bezahlbaren wohnraum zu
schaffen und auch die programme der
städtebauförderung werden wir auf hohem
niveau fortführen denn es geht darum
turbane räume neu zu gestalten den
klimawandel und die klimaanpassung zu
machen und wir sehen wir haben einiges
auf den weg gebracht und für 2023 viel
vor für eine nachhaltige und
zukunftssichere politik vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fdp fraktion hat nun der kollege
daniel für ist das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen frau ministerin
wir haben ja viel einigkeit
wenn wir mal die ft außen vornimmt will
ja wirklich jeder dass die menschen gut
leistbar leben können und der bestand
co2 neutrales und bei allen unkenrufen
zum trotz ist es gut dass wir bei diesen
gigantischen herausforderungen vor denen
das bauen das wohnen und der bestand
stehen ein neues bauministerium
geschaffen haben natürlich geht immer
mehr liebe zu jesus und wir haben jetzt
schon bewiesen dass auf alle fälle mehr
geht wenn ihr nicht mit in der regierung
sein wir haben das garmin ist hier haben
die haushaltsmittel ausgestattet wir
investieren mehr in den sozialen
wohnungsbau es ist legitim dass die dass
die opposition sagt es kann immer mehr
sei da schließe ich mich ja sogar an
natürlich kann immer mehr sein aber im
rahmen des möglichen in rahmen der
mittel die ja schon fest gebunden sind
in milliarden-höhe haben wir neue
akzente gesetzt und für diesen ersten
historischen
haushalt des bauministeriums da kann die
ampel zu recht stolz sein das geht in
die richtige richtung aber
natürlich natürlich ist nach einem
halben jahr noch nicht alles perfekt
natürlich so nicht alle probleme gelöst
wir müssen die angebotslücke schließen
völlig ohne frage es ist ja es ist ja je
nach wissenschaftliche institute
schwankt die zahl an neuen wohnungen die
wir brauchen zwischen 400 bis 700.000
wohnungen im jahr das eine gigantische
aufgabe und diese angebotslücke werden
wir nur schnell nur schließen können
wenn wir die bremsen lösen das bedeutet
planungs beschleunigung und die ampel
hat gezeigt was sie unter planungs
beschleunigung bei den lng terminals
versteht das kann eine blaupause dazu
werden wir die großen bedarf an neuen
wohnungen sitzen ja ich weiß die csu
freunde ganz haft
ich bin ja bereit zu diskutieren und zu
reden und ich schätze ja auch ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen bauen und
wohnen aber immer nur der seiten ruf
mehr warum macht das net kommt nicht mal
vor wittmann vor legt hier immerhin was
ihr konkret volt statt nur vor und da
können wir mal genug zeit im
koalitionsvertrag abschreiben lassen das
ist dann auch schön den können wir
beraten also wir müssen die
angebotslücke schließen ohne zweifel und
da ist es sehr sehr gut dass wir in der
ampel und im koalitionsvertrag erkannt
haben der staat wird das alleine nicht
schaffen wir brauchen den privaten
sektor wir brauchen die kleinen
häuslbauer wir brauchen die
genossenschaften ja wir brauchen auch
den staatlichen städtischen den
kommunalen wohnungsbau es ist alles
richtig und deswegen ist es wichtig dass
wir von kooperation konfrontation auf
kooperationen umstellen was
konfrontation im wohnungsmarkt anrichtet
das zeigt berlin wirklich zur genüge und
da ist dann immer wieder realsatire
wenn ich die kollegin mey höre wie toll
ist alles sei berlin ist funktional und
der wohnungsmarkt in berlin ist
gescheitert
hier
also angebotslücke schließen planungs
beschleunigung
und die biker die baukosten rang ist ja
völlig zurecht formuliert worden dass
die baukosten uns davonlaufen es wird
immer teurer zu bauen und da ist eine
klare antwort meine liebe im kölner das
was ihr letzten jahre nicht gemacht habt
bauforschung stärken bauforschung
stärken wir müssen das die gbt ausbauen
wir müssen mehr in die forschung
investieren wir müssen auch das
entwickelt des seriellen modularen bauen
und sanieren stärke des building
information modeling ist ein ganz
zentraler baustein von der digitalen
planung über über die erstellung bis hin
zum betrieb des gebäudes technologie ist
einer der antworten um die probleme am
wohnungsmarkt zu lösen
was wir darüber hinaus ebenfalls
brauchen
es gibt genug flaschenhälse bei der
frage im wohnungsbau die frage ist
natürlich die kamen hier auch auf wo
bauen wir die neuen boden sind und da
bin ich ja selber der meinung wir können
nicht alles auf der grünen wiese bauen
ich bin felsenfest davon überzeugt dass
wir bei der frage im neubau wegkommen
müssen vom bauland begriff hin zum bau
potenzial begriff wo können wir
aufstocken so können wir um widmen wo
kommen wir um bauen wo es eine brache wo
müssen wir vielleicht doch neubau oder
neues bauland entwickeln das ist eine
entscheidende frage um die knappheit des
baulandes zu lösen indem wir ins boot
enzian gehen und sachen trennen dass wir
immer alles auf der grünen wiese bauen
wollen
abschließend abschließend
die eigentumsquote in
deutschland für ein sowohl haben das
land ich empfinde sie als beschämend wir
sind ganz ganz hinten in europa in der
eu und sie sogar
ganz ganz hinten jetzt kann natürlich
streiten ob der letzte oder vorletzte ob
das ganz ganz hinten ist oder netzwerk
kann man darüber streiten dass die linke
solche debatten für zeigt auch wie
völlig ergebnislose politik macht aber
aber nur in gedanken kurzzeitig zu
machen wir müssen die menschen zeigen
die übrigen eigentum schützt vor
altersarmut nicht nur die generationen
die es erarbeitet und auch generation
darüber hinaus eigene punkt führt zu
einer fairen vermögensverteilung und
eigentum stabilisiert ganze wohnviertel
ganz wohnbereiche deswegen ist
eigentumsförderung ein erklärtes starkes
ziel für 2023 wir kriegen nicht alles in
einem haushalt hin nicht alles in einem
jahr hin aber diese ampel ist für diese
legislaturperiode auf einem sehr sehr
guten weg ich freue mich auf alle
weiteren haushaltsdebatten vielen dank
mehr wohneigentum ist ein
altes in anführungszeichen thema der fdp
auch daniel fürst hat es hier noch mal
thematisiert die große frage ist
natürlich wie man diese eigentumsquote
steigern will denn geld ist nicht immer
so günstig wie im moment nächster redner
michael breilmann aus der unionsfraktion
wir haben ja gerade vom kollegen fürst
einiges an zahlen gehört auch einiges
was man machen sollte ich frage mich nur
warum ihre ganzen vorschläge sich dann
nicht in diesem haushalt wiederfinden
das wundert mich an und sie haben gerade
gesprochen sie haben mehr für forschung
getan wenn ich mir jetzt hier das deck
platz zum einzelplan 25 angucke
forschung untersuchung und ähnliches da
sehe ich eine kürzung von
59.000 eine kürzung ja also wir sollten
vielleicht dann mal mit dem
zahlenmaterial richtig arbeiten unsere
haushälter markus uhl hat da ein auge
drauf
und wir beraten heute abschließend nicht
nur den ersten etat des neuen
bauministeriums
sondern damit auch die umsetzung eines
der zentralen versprechen dieser neuen
bundesregierung ein versprechen dass
olaf scholz auf sich marktplätzen in
deutschland gegeben hat
400.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr davon
100.000 sozialwohnungen und ich finde da
ist es nur fair und das sollten wir
heute auch noch einmal deutlich machen
die haushaltsdebatte zu schauen ob diese
ziele und die haben sie sich selber
gegeben ob diese ziele erreicht werden
können und welche mittel sie dafür auch
haushaltspolitisch eingesetzt haben und
wenn wir uns dann die zahlen und damit
auch anspruch und wirklichkeit dieser
politik jetzt mal angucken und auch die
prognosen die aus der baubranche aus dem
baubereich kommen dann finde ich schon
seltsam mit einigen ausnahmen
selbstkritik bei der fdp ist dabei die
ampel vertreter feiern sich aber hier in
der mehrheit in dieser debatte selbst ob
ihre ansätze einzelne ansätze aber die
realität in diesem lande die ist doch
wirklich eine völlig andere ab 2023 wird
das maximum von neubauwohnungen
schätzungen zufolge bei 250.000
wohnungen die baubranche verhaltens
bereits jetzt für 2023 vor weiterem
gegenwind bauern verschiedene projekte
oder stornieren sie sogar ganz zudem
verteuert sich mit anziehenden kredit
zinsen gerade die finanzierung das ist
alarmierend das zeigt aber auch und das
muss man hier heute mal ansprechen sie
werden ihre ziele vermutlich nicht
erreichen sie werden verfehlt und wir
brauchen
nein das freut uns nicht deswegen geben
wir auch vorschläge und dagegen auch
gleich noch drauf ein denn wir brauchen
hören sie zu wir brauchen einen
vernünftigen mix aus klugen
investitionen neuen freiraum
experimentier fördern auch im bereich
forschung & allrad system sowie stärken
von eigeninitiativen verlässliche
förderbedingungen maßnahmen gegen
baukostensteigerungen baugrundstücke
zügig bereitstellen schnellere
planungsverfahren keine verschärfungen
mietrecht klimaschutz effizient angehen
und steuerrechtliche anreize setzen all
das wirkt geht in der baubranche
angemahnt und auch das muss sich in
einem haushalt am ende wieder für
wir als union wir wollen bauen bauen
bauen denn das ist der beste
mieterschutz aber das einzige was bei
der bundesregierung zementiert wird ist
das nicht erreichen der eigenen ziele
und natürlich spielen da auch
lieferketten probleme material und
fachkräftemangel preis explosion aber
auch das unsägliche förder chaos rund um
die kfw mittel eine rolle und das geht
ja sogar noch weiter ich habe den
gestrigen handels was enorm dass ich
dieses chaos um die kfw-förderung wohl
fortsetzen kann scheinbar könnte es in
absehbarer zeit wieder zu einem stopp
der kfw förderung kommt allein dass das
im handelsblatt steht ob es stimmt oder
nicht ist doch schon eine absolute
katastrophe eine absolute katastrophe
und ich möchte deshalb auch ein wort
hinweisen dass den haushaltsberatungen
eigentlich eine wichtige rolle spielt
das ist das wort planungssicherheit
menschen gerade junge familien deren
eigenschaft eigenheim schaffen wollen
und sicher förderung verlassen haben die
brauchen diese planungssicherheit und
das ganze geld was in diesem haushalt
und wege stehen hinzu ja es gibt auch
erhöhungen es wird auch etwas erhöht zur
verfügung gestellt werden soll das hilft
dann nicht wenn es gleichzeitig an
anderen stellen und gleichzeitig an
anderen stellen dass bauern erschwert
wird und deswegen ist es so enorm
wichtig gerade jetzt zu handeln und auch
wohneigentum zu fördern und dazu gab es
auch vorschläge wir haben diese position
noch einmal deutlich gemacht die
ministerin möchte gerne im bestand
sanieren wir haben dazu einen antrag
gestellt wir wollen wohneigentum fördern
mit dem programm jung kauft alt das ist
alles auch in den haushaltsberatungen
gekommen wir wollen ein gesamtkonzept
für wohnungs eigentumsförderung das
haben sie von der koalition leider
abgelehnt jetzt in diesem haushalt
brauchen wir förderung auch des
eigentums und in diesem sinne ist der
haushalt bau politisch mehr schöner sein
als der große wurf den wir aber dringend
benötigen im sinne aller bauwilligen
aber auch im sinne von mieterin auf dem
platz
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist der kollege bernhard
daldrup für die spd-fraktion
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
präsidentin
haushaltspolitik muss das glaube ich in
zeiten globaler krisen prioritäten nach
den notwendigkeiten derzeit sitzen nach
den notwendigkeiten der zeit und das
gilt nicht nur für die
sicherheitspolitik sondern es gilt für
die wohnungsbaupolitik auch und die
notwendigkeiten der zeit bedeutet eine
antwort auf die frage zu geben wie denn
eigentlich bezahlbarer wohnraum
geschaffen werden kann und die antwort
in dieser koalition lautet im
finanzplanungszeitraum 14,5 milliarden
das ist das dreifache als der letzten
legislaturperiode
das ist eine gewaltige anstrengung eine
deutliche schwerpunkte aktion noch
unterscheidet diese andere position der
letzte bus funktion will dass an dieser
stelle sehr deutlich sagen
ja ich war sehr ich war selber mit tabak
und sie waren nicht derjenige der gesagt
hatte sollen mehr für den sozialen
wohnungsbau zu wenig wenig ziemlich
wir all das ist aber der eine einige
wesentliche unterschied und ich will an
dieser stelle sagen dieser haushalt
steht im zeichen des sozialen
wohnungsbaus neubau sicherung auslaufen
der mietpreisbindung und ich sag mal
gucken sie mal in den sozialen
wohnungsbau in den süddeutschen ländern
das sind in hohem maße eigentums
maßnahmen gucken sie sich das mal an
aber sie wissen es glaube ich gar nicht
dass sie wichtig dass an dieser stelle
ist und ich sag mal von ungefähr ein
drittel jakob kannst du gerne die
statistiken angucken ist es so und
deswegen glaube ich sind andere punkte
dabei die eine rolle spielen dass
genossenschafts programm jahrelang
verhindert worden ehrlich gesagt kommt
jetzt mit sechs millionen ein leichter
anfang damit man auch eigentumsbildung
in den städten durchführen kann was
wollten sie aber nicht
ich will noch mal dazu sagen liebe
tassen leid es ist keineswegs so dass
wir an unseren zielen scheitern wir
kämpfen um diese ziele das ist
eigentlich ein klassisches merkmal von
linken-politikern gewesen und nicht
aufgeben und sagen die haben gescheitert
denn trotz globaler krise trotz
wohnungsmangel mietpreisentwicklung oder
klimawandel können wir ja die arbeit
nicht sozusagen einfach aussetzen und
wie können sie auch nicht lieber mit
seiner gegeneinander stellen wir müssen
den klimawandel und den klimaschutz
berücksichtigen und das bezahlbare
wohnen und das ist kein gegensatz doch
das machen wir ganz gut ich hab eben
schon gesagt dass ward über und ich sage
immer auch dazu wir haben die
experimentallabor eingeführt da die
union nur zugeguckt mit den 250
millionen und wir haben jetzt 790
millionen in der städtebauförderung
damit die daraus entwickeln konzepte
umgesetzt werden können das ist die idee
dabei und wir machen beim mit 10
millionen dann thema beim thema wenn
beispielsweise die fortsetzung damit es
schneller geht damit preiswerter
realisiert werden kann das was daniel
fürst eben angesprochen hat also mit
anderen worten die punkte sind schon
richtig bei uns aufgehoben wohnen ist
eben keine x-beliebige war vonn ist
nicht einfach einen markt buch sondern
die sozialpflichtigkeit spielt dabei
eine rolle und deswegen ist die miete
und politik auch wichtig erscheint auch
ihr thema ich vermute dass sie gleich
mal das sagen zur begrenzung von
indexmiete das ist nämlich ein zentrales
problem zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt und
wir werden uns darauf auch zum vortag
aus recht behandelt behandelt und ich
finde ich ehrlich gesagt wie über die
beamer gesprochen wird die bima ist zum
partner der kommunen und kommen in der
der städte und gemeinden geworden die
bima stellt in großem umfang wohnungen
beziehungsweise unterkunftsmöglichkeiten
für die unterbringung von flüchtlingen
aus der ukraine zur verfügung das findet
sich nirgendwo positiv gewürdigt und ich
finde das muss man politik für die bei
realen wohnungsbestand von 39.000
wohnungen mit ricke leerstandsquote
nicht mal zwei prozent und es wird
massiv modernisiert in der biber ich
finde das muss man auf diese art und
weise kann glaube ich jedenfalls auch
mal darstellen ich will
noch ein paar andere punkte hier
ansprechen überschlagen sozusagen ein
stück hat jedenfalls meiner meiner miete
will einer redet entschuldigung will
aber auch darauf aufmerksam machen dass
natürlich auch dazu gehört was sie
angesprochen worden ist der umbau von
wohnungen im rahmen des altersgerechten
umbau des wohnungsbestandes 75 millionen
stehen dafür zur verfügung reicht nicht
war aber nie mehr wo ich mal sagen war
nie mehr zu keinem zeitpunkt genauso
übrigens wie die mittel für den sozialen
wohnungsbau auch um den anträgen der
linken in der letzten wahlperiode nie
mehr waren will das mal an dieser stelle
doch deutlich sagen das ist mir auch ein
wichtiger gesichtspunkt und ich will
darauf aufmerksam machen dass wir jetzt
um die emissionen im gebäudebestand
kümmern müssen dass wir den
gebäudebestand effizienter machen müssen
deswegen gibt es einen co2 preis und die
union will dass dieser co2 preis nur von
mietenden von mieterinnen und mietern
bezahlt wird das ist ihr ausdrückliches
ziel sie haben das andere verhindert und
deswegen machen wir jetzt dieses zehn
stufen modell um auf diese art und weise
zu einer gerechten lösung mit
anreizwirkungen zu kommen leider läuft
dir meine zeit bei mir immer schneller
als andere weiß auch nicht wie das kommt
und
deswegen will ich noch zwei drei sätze
zu sagen zu den kommunen bei diesem
ministerium geht sehr sehr deutlich die
kommunale handlungsfähigkeit von der
städtebauförderung bis zu den vielen
programmen angesprochen die wir helfen
die altschuldenhilfe ist übrigens auch
so ein thema um handlungsfähigkeit
herzustellen vielleicht tut sich ja
jetzt neuerdings was in nordrhein
westfalen weil die grünen hier ein
schnuppert mit drängeln und mithelfen
das wäre jedenfalls wünschenswert
herzlichen dank war
das wort hat die abgeordnete carolyn
bachmann für die fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin wäre die kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren wir erleben
eine zeitenwende die wohn teuer und
bauen unattraktiv macht
hauptverantwortlich sind sie und die
vorgängerregierung in der vergangenheit
spielte der wohnungsbaupolitik eher eine
untergeordnete rolle das war waren
urbanisierung und wohnungsmangel in den
ballungsgebieten bereits im blickfeld
das wohl war aber grundsätzlich
bezahlbar die bürger konnten frei
entscheiden wo und wie sie wohnen
möchten der handwerker war erschwinglich
die baukosten relativ konstant und das
material vorhanden
doch heute stehen wir politisch
induziert vor städtischer wohnungsnot
einem vernachlässigten ländlichen raum
überfüllung mit flüchtlingen und einer
viel zu abhängig und daher fragilen
wertschöpfungskette die unsere
eigenversorgung nicht mehr gewährleisten
kann die folgen sind jetzt für alle
spürbar
auf der einen seite explodierenden miet
und nebenkosten und auf der anderen
seite steigen die baukosten und fehlt
baumaterial
wohnen bauen sind grundbedürfnisse
das haben sie sogar im koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten aber
von ihren versprechungen ausreichend und
bezahlbaren wohnraum zu schaffen sind
sie meilenweit entfernt
wohnen bauen
wird für immer mehr menschen zum problem
sowohl neubau als auch sanierung werden
durch ihre politik immer
unwirtschaftlicher
baustoffe sind bis zu 77 prozent teurer
und sie wollten die dafür ursächliche
geldmenge noch weiter aus wir haben in
deutschland die höchste steuer und
abgabenlast und sie belasten mieter und
vermieter noch mit völlig sinnlosen co2
abgaben und weil das alles noch nicht
reicht knechten sie die bürger weiter
mit ihrer gebäude energieverordnung mit
ihrem dämpfern und immer steigenden
anforderungen an den bau
und sie rühmt sich mit dem ziel jährlich
400.000 wohnungen zu errichten
da fragt sich auch die immobilienbranche
wie sie auf diese utopische zahl von
jährlich 400.000 wohnungen eigentlich
kommen macht auch meine anfrage hin
wussten sie nicht einmal wie viel lohn
und überhaupt in deutschland leer stehen
woher wissen sie dann wie viele
wohnungen überhaupt benötigt werden
genauso aus der luft gegriffen wie diese
zahl 400.000 ist auch ihr haushaltsplan
ihr haushalt bietet keine lösung und
verbesserung für das bauen und wohnen
deutschland und ihr haushalt bietet auch
kein anreiz für die soziale
marktwirtschaft und bewegt den markt
nicht selbst die wohnung zu schaffen
frau ministerin wir empfehlen ihnen
kommen sie weg von ihrer großstadt
fokussierten wohnungspolitik
verschaffen sie sich einen überblick
über den leerstand und legen sie ein
sanierungsprogramm auf und machen sie
den ländlichen raum infrastrukturell
wieder attraktiv damit die leute aus den
städten wieder zurück ins land ziehen
können
reduzieren sie ideologie statt
staatswirtschaft finden sich stattdessen
zurück sozialen marktwirtschaft und
stärken sie die eigentumsrechte der
bürger so ich habe man nämlich
ausreichend denn und bezahlbaren
wohnraum
ihr haushalt geht aktuell am konkreten
bedarf und an den zukunftsproblem der
bürger vorbei vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun die kollegin carolin otto das
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau vorziehen sehr geehrte
damen und herren bei diesen
haushaltsverhandlungen konnten wir klar
machen welchen unterschied die ampel
macht wir geben die großen
herausforderungen an
große abstrakte herausforderungen werden
vor ort in den kommunen ganz konkret in
der panini in den gesundheitsämtern und
krankenhäuser im krieg russlands gegen
die ukraine durch die geflüchteten in
den gemeinden in der klimakrise durch
überhitzte städte und überflutete
siedlung
unsere städte gemeinden und landkreise
machen einen wahnsinns job wenn sie an
vorderster front dafür sorgen dass
gesellschaft nicht an diesen
herausforderungen zerbricht
[Applaus]
die kommunen sind der ort an dem wir
dafür sorgen müssen dass menschen dabei
bleiben sich nicht abkoppeln sich nicht
im stich gelassen fühlen die
verantwortung die kommunen tragen ist
gigantisch ihre rolle bei allem was wir
hier in berlin entscheiden können
zentral das bröckelnde fundament der
kommunalen finanzen wieder auf stabile
füße zu stellen das ist eine zentrale
zukunftsaufgabe
mit dem haushalt 2022 gehen wir einen
richtigen schritt in die richtige
richtung um kommunen finanziell besser
auszustatten
im etat des bauministeriums schaffen wir
mehr als doppelt so viel geld für
kommunale sanierungsprojekte es geht um
475 millionen euro mehr für sporthallen
jugendzentren und schwimmbäder vor ort
wir unterstützen können bei den
zentralen herausforderungen unserer zeit
über den gesamten haus teilchen weg doch
letztes jahr wurde die nationale
klimaschutzinitiative
neu ausgerichtet auch um den
bedürfnissen des kommunalen
klimaschutzes gerecht zu werden mit dem
haushalt 2022 sichern wir die
finanzierung der deutlich steigenden
nachfrage denn klimaschutz entscheidet
sich vor ort
kommunen sind halde transformationen
folgen von transformationsprozessen sind
vor ort nicht immer leicht wegzustecken
den haushaltsansatz für die
gemeinschaftsaufgabe regionale
wirtschaftsentwicklung haben wir deshalb
im parlamentarischen verfahren um 25
millionen euro erhöht die
gemeinschaftsaufgabe ist ein zentrales
instrument um strukturschwache region
nachhaltig zu stärken
der weg ist noch weit bis wir kommunen
ihrer rolle angemessen finanziell
ausstatten aber mit dem haushalt 2022
laufen in die richtige richtung mit dem
haushalt 20 23 müssen wir den
eingeschnittenen weg eingeschlagenen weg
weitergehen und noch größere schritte
wagen für die haus handlungsfähigkeit
der kommunen ist es entscheidend dass
wir die alte schule die frage lösen die
unterbringung und versorgung von
geflüchteten braucht eine langfristige
finanzielle lösung für den kommunalen
klimaschutz
auch ist größere lösung hier müssen wir
neue wege zwischen land und ländern und
bund finden und 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr die mögen langfristig für
mehr verteidigungs und bündnisfähigkeit
sorgen aber
es ist gut dass wir das im haushalt
lösen aber das darf nicht unsere antwort
auf zeitenwende bleiben die menschen
erwarten und brauchen mehr
dieses mehr müssen wir im haushalt 20 23
finanzieren und damit ist jetzt zeit
über steuererhöhungen zu sprechen damit
alle einen fairen beitrag leisten um die
kosten der krise zu sichern zu schultern
und
um die großen zukunftsinvestitionen zu
leisten ist auch eine debatte über die
schulden werden sie für den haushalt 20
23 einfach notwendig alles andere würde
aktuellen lage nicht gerecht
carolin otto und vor allem auch ihre
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen mal mit
dem koalitionspartner der fdp sprechen
müssen was so die schuldenbremse im
nächsten jahr angelangt
wo ich lange von der unionsfraktion hat
es das wort
frau für sie denn den liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
ob es historisch ist lasse ich mal offen
aber wir freuen uns alle dass wir heute
nach 25 jahren circa 25 jahren erstmals
wieder einen haushalt eines
bauministeriums beschließen ich sage
aber auch ganz offen da ist auch
enttäuschung mit dabei ein ministerium
mit mangelnder kompetenz bima und kfw
eine ministerin mit mangelnder
durchsetzungsfähigkeit beamer und kfw
und lieber kollege daldrup bevor wir zur
legendenbildung über den sozialen
wohnungsbau kommen ich helfe aber gern
noch mal nach seit wann ist sozialer
wohnungsbau wieder eine bundesaufgabe
seit wann sind wir verantwortlich zeit
der letzten periode also hier sind
vorwürfe fallt wir und horst seehofer
und gehandelt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ja und wer war der finanzminister für
das bereitstellen der mittel für den
sozialen wohnungsbau in der letzten
legislaturperiode
olaf scholz ist der finanzminister und
mehr geld gab's halt vom heutigen
bundeskanzler nicht liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen nämlich beim nächsten thema
auch wenn es ein dauerbrenner werden
wird natürlich ist es schwieriger
geworden zu bauen die zinsen steigen das
material die fachkräfte aber wesentlich
ist natürlich ihr
förderkreis und wer hat nicht
ausreichend fördermittel zur verfügung
gestellt es war der finanzminister der
letzten legislatur es war olaf scholz
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
nun mal die wirklichkeit mit der auch
sie sich liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der spd auseinandersetzen müssen und
dann würde ich doch mal sagen frau
ministerin
machen sie den menschen nichts vor
1,6 millionen wohnungen werden in dieser
legislatur nicht gebaut wir bedauern das
aber man sollte ehrlich zu den menschen
sein wenn man glaubwürdig politik machen
will und hier sitzt noch jemand der aus
der letzten periode ganz genau weiß wie
komplex es werden wird das ist auch eine
frage von respekt wie ich die menschen
gegenüber
kommuniziere wohnraum offensive liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben in
der letzten periode gezeigt mit mehr als
300.000 gebauten wohnungen wie wohnraum
offensive geht wie wohnraum offensive
geht und an diesen müssen sie sich jetzt
in dieser periode messen lassen und da
wird es nichts nutzen die
genossenschaftsanteile schauen sie doch
mal in ihren haushalt rein wie viel geld
steht denn da drin für die
genossenschaftsanteile da sind ein paar
hunderttausend
euro damit lösen sie doch nicht das ist
ein mosaik aber erhöhen sie nicht mosaik
als ob sie damit allgemeine lösungen
gefunden hätten
ich hab die uhr eingehalten nein ich
will noch mal ich will noch mal dran
läuft weiter nein ich will noch einmal
darauf hinweisen auch das gehört dazu
damit man hier nicht wieder falsche
dinge sagt das baukindergeld 400.000
anträge 710000 kinder haben ein eigenes
dach über den kopf bekommen auch das ist
echte wohnraumförderung auch das ist
eigentum auch das ist familienpolitik
das ist union und das haben wir gemacht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
neuauflage des programms sanierung
kommunaler einrichtungen begrüßen wir
die haushalts trickserei haben wir
verstanden es kommt jetzt aus dem egf wo
das geld des egf er kommt wird sich auch
vor dem verfassungsgericht noch klären
lassen dass sie selber nicht an die
weichenstellungen der neuen regierung
glauben zeigt ihr antrag im
haushaltsausschuss liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der ampel
ansonsten hätten sie keinen antrag
gestellt in dem sie die regierung
auffordern ein programm zur förderung
des erwerbs von eigentum aufzulegen sie
müssen nicht die regierung auffordern
sie sind die regierungen jährigen den
fraktionen tun sie's handeln sie wir
sind gespannt auf den antrag und auf den
haushalt 23 dankeschön ulrich lange der
fraktionsvize der union ja die bima die
bundesanstalt für immobilienaufgaben die
hat er angesprochen anja der größten
immobilien eigentümerin in deutschland
gehören nach eigenen angaben
rund 39.000 wohnungen für die mächtige
behörde ist allerdings nicht klara
geywitz zuständig sondern dass der
bundes baufeld unter den bereich von
christian den er aus der fdp jetzt eine
kurzinformation von afrika schade dass
ihm eine zwischenfrage nicht zu glatt
haben denn es war einfach eine wissens
frage die ich hatte ich höre den reden
der cdu csu seit heute morgen zu und
höre immer mehr immer mehr immer mehr
das mag ja auch berechtigt seien aber
deswegen würde mich interessieren bei
all der kritik was wir nicht machen und
was sie mehr machen wollen könnten sie
nur ungefähre zahl dessen sagen was
ihnen an millionen oder milliarden in
diesem haushalt fehlt einfach dass ich
das nur weiß dann kann ich das auch in
den rest der woche auch so ein bisschen
berücksichtigen weil das ist etwas was
mich einfach interessiert wo nach ihrer
meinung es fehlt an zahlen vielleicht
eine konkrete grobe zahl ich will sie da
auch nicht zu sehr beim worten immer war
irgendwie sowas wo sie den betrag nennen
können der ihnen fehlt sagt der
haushälter der liberalen otto fricke
oder fragt bzw
liebe kollegen fricke ich danke für den
hinweis auf die gewaltenteilung ich
glaube das verstehen wir beide wie
gewaltenteilung funktioniert und sie als
rechtsstaatspartei wissen dass er in
ganz besonderem maße und trotzdem
funktioniert politik und umsetzung und
regieren dadurch dass man als koalition
die eine regierung trägt auch
entsprechend sie rühmen sich ja für
ihren koalitionsvertrag dann auch
entsprechend das umsetzt auch das
umsetzt was man sich in einer regierung
vorgenommen hat auch das gehört zum
verständnis einer
parlamentarischen demokratie
und genau das sind wir hier und dafür
sind wir hier das spiegelbild also
insofern denke ich haben wir diese frage
doch ausreichend geklärt und auf die
frage des immer mehr lieber kollege
fricke sie haben ja die vorschläge von
uns auf dem tisch werden die vorschläge
zur eigentumsförderung in der letzten
sitzungswoche diskutiert ich habe ihnen
ganz deutlich gesagt dass wir begrüßen
wenn man die kommunalen einrichtungen
für wieder fördert ich sage ihnen aber
auch dass wir natürlich ganz genau sehen
wie sies haushalterisch verbuchen dann
gipfel
ja soweit ulrich danke nochmal hier mit
der erwiderung auf otto fricke also die
beamer bleibt also absehbar beim
finanzministerium da gab es gerade jetzt
ist eine anfrage dazu und damit das
immobilienvermögen des bundes das nicht
unter direktem zugriff der
bundesbauministeriums stehen wird
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir haben heute schon sehr
viele über zahlen gesprochen das ja auch
herrn haushaltsdebatte nicht unüblich
ist aber ich will auch noch mal den
blick darauf richten das werden wir über
den haushalt des ministeriums für wohnen
bauen stadtentwicklung und kommunen
debattieren ist ja eigentlich um viel
mehr geht es geht um ort in den menschen
leben es geht um lebensqualität um
zukunft und um heimat gerade besonders
unsere städte sind der platz an dem
unsere haushaltspolitik die wir heute
hier debattieren spür und erlebt habe
städte und kommunen spielen seit jeher
eine der entscheidenden rollen dabei
unser gemeinwohl zu schützen und den
menschen in diesem land sicherheit und
identifikation zu geben sie sind heimat
und an kam sie stellen soziale
gerechtigkeit her und treiben die
transformationen an zu erfüllen diese
aufgaben benötigt es jedoch natürlich
auch geld gut investiertes geld das
heißt der fortschreitende klimawandel
die aufnahmen von geflüchteten sei es
der umgang mit wirtschaftlichen
strukturwandel und transformation mit
all diesen herausforderungen müssen
städte und kommunen fertig werden und
die als grund lassen sie damit nicht
allein der bund wird auch in diesem jahr
in diesem haushalt erhebliche
finanzielle mittel nämlich 790 millionen
euro für die städtebauförderung
aufwenden
es bedient auf jeden fall aus der
das geld macht unsere städte und
gemeinden zu lebenswerten orten an denen
soziale verankerungen gelingt seit der
sozialliberalen koalition unter willy
brandt also seit mehr als 50 jahren gibt
es bereits die städtebauförderung mit
der die bundesregierung die kommunale
stadtentwicklung unterstützt eine
sozialliberale erfolgsgeschichte quasi
die wir jetzt als ampel fortschreiben
und zwar nicht nur mit 790 millionen
euro sondern zusätzlich stellen wir noch
775 millionen euro für die neue
förderrunde des programms nationale
projekte der städte baus bereit
ich finde dass es ein starkes signal an
die menschen in unserem land auch in
einer zeit in der wir mit hohen
anforderungen an den bundeshaushalt
konfrontiert sind in einer zeit in der
zu recht von deutschland ein starkes
internationales engagement erwartet wird
auch in dieser zeit machen wir uns stark
dafür den menschen dieses landes eine
lebenswerte heimat zu schaffen und zu
erhalten
wir wollen gemeinwohl orientiert und
gerechte städte mit einem starken
sozialen zusammenhalt deswegen ist es
unser ziel die wohn und lebensqualität
sowie die nutzungsvielfalt in den
quartieren zu erhöhen die integration
aller bevölkerungsgruppen zu
unterstützen und den zusammenhalt in
unserem nachbarschaften zu stärken dafür
werden wir das programm sozialen
zusammenhalt als nachfolgeprogramm des
extrem erfolgreichen soziale stadt
programms auch weiter fördern genau
diesen sozialen zusammenhalt zu stärken
ist auch das ziel des kfw
sonderprogramms für flüchtlings
unterbringung mit dem wir bereits vor
wochen auch die flüchtlingsbewegung auch
so keine nach deutschland reagiert haben
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt schafft
man auch in dem man orte ford fördert in
den menschen gemeinsam sport machen
kultur erleben oder einfach nur feste
feiern gerade in corona zeiten haben wir
gemerkt wie schmerzhafter verlust dieser
begegnungsmöglichkeiten ist deshalb bin
ich besonders froh dass es gelungen ist
jedoch stolze summe von 476 millionen
euro für die sanierung kommunaler
einrichtungen in den bereichen sport
jugend und kultur bereitzustellen es ist
mir auch wichtig sie mir wichtig hier
besonders das wort jugend zu
unterstreichen unsere jugend hat unter
der prohner zeit besonders gelitten ihr
wurden wertvolle jahren wichtige
erfahrungen genommen deshalb hat sie es
verdient dass wir für sie und künftige
generationen schöne orte schaffen in
denen sie sport treiben freunde treffen
und auch feiern können junge menschen
sollen schließlich nicht ihre jugend
hier im bundestag auf opfern müssen
sondern sie im freibad verbringen oder
im sportverein
und last but not least sollen unsere
städte und gemeinden grüneren
nachhaltigere orte werden ich komme aus
mannheim eine der wärmsten städte
deutschlands dort erlebe ich jeden
sommer die notwendigkeit in der stadt
raum zum atmen zu schaffen
raum zum abkühlen und schatten dass dies
in der regel nur mit steuergeld zu
verwirklichen ist bin ich sehr froh dass
es im rahmen des klimafonds gelungen ist
176 millionen für die anpassung obama
orte an den klimawandel bereitzustellen
und wir werden auch die raumordnung
anfassen um platz zu schaffen für
erneuerbare energien
unsere städte und kommunen ist
angesichts zahlreicher gleichzeitiger
krise noch resilient und
anpassungsfähigen genau da setzen unsere
bundesprogramme der städtebauförderung
an eine gerechte nachhaltige und
lebenswerte heimat für uns alle zu
schaffen vielen dank
isabel kategorie war das für die
sozialdemokraten hat sie gesprochen ist
im ausschuss für wohnen stadtentwicklung
und kommunen das ist bei den
haushaltsberatungen bei den einzelnen
etats dass wir uns über die woche weiter
verfolgen können immer ein wechsel gibt
dann haushaltspolitiker die natürlich zu
den einzelplänen da den blick drauf
haben und dann gibt es die fachpolitiker
zu dem jeweiligen ressort
ich bin ja ganz froh dass sie am schluss
der debatte noch ein bisschen schwung in
das ganze kommt wir wollen ja nicht nur
über zahlen reden sondern wir sitzen ja
hier als baupolitiker zusammen uns geht
es darum dass tatsächlich in unserem
land auch gebaut wird insofern hat die
ministerin ja völlig recht ich gesagt
das bauministerium
ist oder besser sollte ein investitions
ministerium sein da stimmen wir voll und
ganz zu nur da muss man dann schon mal
anschauen was ist denn eigentlich der
anspruch der formuliert wird von der
ministerin der im koalitionsvertrag
formuliert wird und was ist die
wirklichkeit und da muss man schon sagen
da klaffen anspruch und wirklichkeit
aber ganz erheblich auseinander ist ja
schon angesprochen worden das war eine
der ersten maßnahmen diese ampel
regierung gemacht hat ein beispielloses
chaos bei der förderung bei der karte an
zurück in ein beispielloses chaos was
vertrauen massiv zerstört hat was dazu
geführt hat dass vielen jungen familien
dass bauherren unter den füßen die
finanzierung weggezogen worden ist und
dass zehntausende von projekte nicht
verwirklicht worden sind das gegenteil
von dem gemacht was ich ihr heute
vorgetragen haben das geht so nicht und
das ist ja nun schon das ist ja nun
schon im januar gewesen jetzt sind da 31
dabei also schon einige monate später
aber was ist seitdem passiert es ist ja
bis heute immer noch nicht klar wie geht
es eigentlich mit der förderung weiter
wir haben momentan einen riesigen
atheismus projekte werden zurückgestellt
in größenordnung der gew hat gesagt über
60 prozent ihrer mitgliedsunternehmen
habe gesagt sie stellen projekte zurück
das sind zehntausende von wohnungen die
aktuell nicht realisiert werden weil die
menschen weil die bauherren nicht wissen
in welche richtung muss mehr projekte
entwickeln welche kriterien muss ich
denn erfüllen um in den genuss einer
förderung zu bekommen da haben sie bis
heute keinerlei klarheit geschaffen wir
brauchen investitionssicherheit
planungssicherheit
und kam jetzt das förderprogramm so
aufgesetzt dass man dort die
nachhaltigkeit in den mittelpunkt stellt
das ist ja auch in ordnung sind wir
überhaupt gar nicht gegen als union ein
qs siegel zu machen dort an der stelle
aber wenn wir mal fragt wie viele
stellen gibt es denn eigentlich in
deutschland die das auch zertifizieren
können die denn diejenigen die so bauen
wollen sie jetzt vorgegeben da gibt es
überhaupt gar nicht so viele sie haben
riesigen kapazitätsengpass an der stelle
selbst wenn es leute gebe die das machen
wollen können sie es nicht weil nicht
zertifiziert werden kann und deswegen
glaube ich müssen sie ihrem anspruch
auch taten folgen lassen da fehlt uns zu
wenig und wenn wir jetzt schon von
ansprechen sprechen
wir haben das jahr gesehen als union das
jetzt auch im haushalt geplant wird ein
konzept für die eigentumsförderung
vorzulegen das soll jetzt alles geplant
werden das kommt aber erst irgendwann im
nächsten jahr oder vielleicht auch nicht
im nächsten jahr und da muss ich mich
schon fragen wenn ihr gesagt wird es
soll ein konzept der arbeit wenn es gibt
doch diese konzepte wir haben die
konzepte doch auch wir reden doch nicht
heute das erste mal über
eigentumsförderung wir haben über das
baukindergeld schon gesprochen was viele
zehntausend familie in die eigenen vier
wände gebracht hat gerade die schweden
haushalte die ist so schwer haben bei
ihnen das eigenkapital fehlt die haben
ja mit dem bau kinder gezüchtigt ihren
traum von den eigenen vier wänden zu
leben das haben wir gemacht und sie im
haushalt treffen noch nicht einmal dafür
vorsorge dass diejenigen die ein
anspruch darauf haben auch wirklich
tatsächlich dieses geld in anspruch
nehmen können es droht momentan ein
weiterer vertrauensbruch weil
baukindergeld nicht in anspruch genommen
werden kann und es gibt andere konzepte
sie haben im koalitionsvertrag das doch
alles formuliert die freibeträge bei der
grunderwerbssteuer eigenkapital ersetzen
da lädt mietkauf moderne steuerliche
abschreibung der nachfrage ich doch mal
gerichtet an die fdp wo sind sie denn
haben sie ihre durchsetzungskraft bei
corona verloren dann machen sie doch mal
diese konzepte
man kann daran feststellen der traum von
den eigenen vier wänden das was vier von
fünf deutschen leben wollen in den
eigenen vier wänden diesen traum zu
erleben das hat offensichtlich keine
priorität für die ampel und das bedauern
wir als union ganz ausdrücklich und ich
will herr kollege darum einen punkt noch
ansprechen weil sie mich auch direkt
adressiert haben die co2 kosten das
ulmer kollege lutz gestalten sie eine
frage oder bemerkungen des kollegen
vielen dank kollege luft dass ich sie
trage zu lassen ich würde ganz gerne von
ihnen wissen
wie lange ist eigentlich diese ampel
koalition ist in der regierung und was
glauben sie kann man in diesen
zeiträumen vom koalitionsvertrag alles
realisieren 80 90 oder 100 prozent
zweite frage
zweite frage ist wenn sie wenn sie die
wenn sie die zertifizierung wenn sie die
zertifizierung begrüßen wie kann es
eigentlich sein dass der
fortschrittliche horst seehofer an
dieser zertifizierung und offensichtlich
hat ist die csu und die cdu nie
gefordert noch nie etwas gemacht hat so
dass das jetzt begonnen werden muss und
die dritte frage wenn ein förderprogramm
p55 von ursprünglich 5 milliarden
hinterher auf 16 milliarden hochgeht und
festgestellt werden muss dass die
klimapolitische intention jedenfalls
gott sei dank nicht mehr in dem maße
ausschlaggebend ist wie im anfang also
das programm seinen zweck erfüllt hat
wie hoch hätte denn eigentlich die
zusätzliche weitergehende förderung in
diesem programm sein müssen und welchen
deckungsvorschlag hätten sie dafür
gemacht
vielen dank herr kundige dadurch für die
zwischenfrage zur ersten frage sind wir
gefragt
was die dauer beamte anbelangt und also
erst mal kann ich sagen die amt ist
etwas viel zu lange in der regierung und
wir arbeiten daran dass sich das
möglichst schnell ändert an der stimme
was die
was die frage der nachhaltigkeit umbauen
angelangt und die zertifizierung noch
mal da sind wir sehr dafür und natürlich
muss man auch programme fortentwicklung
deswegen sagen wir als union auch
selbstverständlich kann man auch den
lebenszyklus co2 und das alles in
förderung einbeziehen aber unser
zentraler kritikpunkt und den können sie
auch an der stelle nicht in kraft ist
sie müssen den menschen
planungssicherheit geben sie können doch
nicht ein programm abbrechen oder das
gewicht völlig klar ist was kommt an
dieser stelle sonst passiert nämlich
genau das was wir jetzt haben die
menschen brauchen nicht weil sie nicht
wissen berühmten bauten und deswegen
geht es am ende hier um die
verlässlichkeit politik braucht
verlässliche oder muss verlässliche
rahmenbedingungen herstellen damit wir
unsere ziele erreichen können und es
geht um bezahlbares bauen und wohnen es
geht um klimafreundliches bauen und
wohnen und wenn wir dort nicht klare
linien geben den bauwilligen der
investoren und auch den jungen familien
die bei willich sind wir mit denen dort
nicht klare rahmenbedingungen vorgeben
und das pferd ist bei der ampel dann
wird das mit ihren zielen 1,6 millionen
wohnungen in dieser legislaturperiode
niemals klappen und da sind wir andere
auch was um sie müssen die plan
sicherheit herstellen sie rühmen sich
jetzt in der regierungsverantwortung zu
sein dann regieren sie aber auch und
gestalten sie den rahmen so dass die
menschen sich auch darauf einstellen
können
ich bleibe auch gerne bei ihm erkundigt
druck weil sie ja mich vorhin in ihrer
rede auch direkt adressiert haben was
die co2 kosten anbelangt und da muss ich
ihnen schon sagen das modell was sie
jetzt hier vorschlagen wo sie sagen das
ist so tolles modell und das stützt auf
energieeffizienz dieses modell ist eine
moritz hat das ist eine mogelpackung es
kommt der ihrem modell ja überhaupt gar
nicht darauf an ob jemand in seinem
gebäude investiert hat ob er investiert
hat dass es energetisch modernisiert
wird und einem guten start darauf kommt
es nicht an sondern sie haben ihr modell
alleine den ansatz dass man auf die
verbrauchten heizkosten abstellt und
danach wird ein gebäude klassifiziert
und danach wird aufgeteilt wer welchen
anteil von kosten zu tragen hat und da
muss ich doch schon mal sagen die frage
wie viel brennstoff verbraucht wird das
ist ja nur von ganz vielen faktoren
abhängig das hängt davon ab wo steht ein
gebäude in welcher region das hängt vor
allem davon ab wer wohnt in diesem
gebäude und ihr vorschlag darauf
abgestellt bedeutet am ende dass
diejenigen menschen die einen hohen reiz
verbraucher haben das sind ältere
menschen das sind junge kinderreiche
familie dass die durchs raster fallen
werden weil sich jeder vermieter
natürlich überlegen wird will ich dir
als mieter haben oder nicht und deswegen
kann ihr modell keine zukunft haben das
ist eine freie steuerungswirkung wir
brauchen eine lenkungswirkung bei der
co2 für jeden markt für mieterinnen und
mieter was das nutzer zeit haben aber
eben auch anreize zu investieren
deswegen brauchen wir ein abgestuftes
modell kombiniert mit steuerlichen
förderung und da finden wir überhaupt
kollegen müssen sie jetzt mit ihrem
kollegen gerald kopp an anderer stelle
weiter klären sie müssen den punkt
setzen das mache ich sehr gerne gaben an
vielen stellen noch gelegenheit dazu wir
brauchen zeiten wenn eine gemeinsame
kraft einstellung dieser haushalt das
ist keine kraftanstrengungen sondern er
ist insgesamt eine mogelpackung viel zu
wenige eigene akzente und deswegen
werden wir ihn so auch nicht mittragen
vielen dank wie jan marco luczak war das
für die union ihr aber bei diesem thema
co2 kosten wer soll zahlen vermieter
oder mieter da ist ja die kohle die
große koalition einer letzten legislatur
überhaupt nicht zueinander gekommen
jetzt will die neue bundesregierung die
vermieter künftig an der klimaabgabe bei
heizkosten beispielsweise beteiligen
sehr geehrte frau ministerin gallwitz
liebe kolleginnen kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren wir können natürlich
noch viel vergangenheit bewältigung der
union hier betreiben aber dafür bleibt
nicht die zeit
sonst hätte ich gerne danach gefragt wie
letzte bundeskanzlerin hieß und wenn sie
vielleicht die gelegenheit nutzen
sprechen sie mal mit herrn altmaier baum
ist so ein café chaos gab das wäre
ehrlich
ehrlich darauf ihre antwort an herrn
kollegen der gruppe als sie gesagt haben
sie machen nicht politik für die
menschen sondern um die ampel abzuwehren
wir machen politik für die menschen
deswegen möchte ich zu meinen eigenen
thema von
wohnungslosigkeit ist nicht gleich
obdachlosigkeit ist mir wichtig dass
hier einmal klar anzusprechen denn
vielfach wird dies gleich gesetzt doch
von den schätzungsweise
256.000 wohnungslosen in deutschland
sind rund 40.000 menschen obdachlos um
all diese menschen müssen wir uns
kümmern wenn wir über das thema wohnen
sprechen
wohnen muss bezahlbar sein punkt wie
sehr dieser einfache satz aber das leben
dominieren kann habe ich aus gesprächen
in meiner heimat erfahren deswegen
möchte ich einen kurzen
einen kurzen blick auf eine geschichte
werfen die ich zugetragen bekommen habe
ein mensch der wohnungslos und dann
obdachlos geworden ist durch mehrere
schicksalsschläge in eine lebenskrise
gestürzt ist suchtproblem hatte
arbeitsplatzverlust entfremdung des
privaten umfeldes
beziehungsende er ist jetzt erstmals
wieder in einen eigenen raum gekommen
durch eine einrichtung der diakonie
er hat jetzt die perspektive auf eigenem
wohnraum und wird dabei begleitet
auch um diese menschen geht wenn wir
ambitionierte ziele setzen insbesondere
beim thema wohnen
denn
unsere ziele und meilensteine sind nur
so viel wert wie sie auch den ärmsten
teil der bevölkerung zugute kommen umso
wichtiger ist es dass wir dieses jahr
zum ersten mal eine belastbare statistik
bekommen um wohnungslosigkeit zu messen
das ist ein erster meilenstein und in
den kommenden jahren gezielte maßnahmen
auf den weg zu bringen
und ich bin mir dessen bewusst dass wir
uns das ziel gegeben haben bis 2030 die
wohnungslosigkeit zu überwinden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist eine
herausforderung aber wir können das
schaffen in dem wir auch die
wohnungswirtschaft stärker in
verantwortung nehmen gleichzeitig müssen
wir die institutionen und akteure mehr
unterstützen die sich jeden tag mit
voller kraft den wohnungslosen menschen
widmen in unserem land
aus meinen austausch mit der
bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft
wohnungslosenhilfe
nämlich mit an fehlendem wissen und
innovativen ideen mangelt es nicht
einig sind ein zentraler baustein stellt
zu diesem zweck der angekündigte
nationale aktionsplan wohnungslosigkeit
da unsere ministerin wird damit einen
effektiven weg aufzeigen wie wir die
wohnungslosigkeit bis 2030 überwinden
werden ich freue mich zudem sehr dass
die ministerin bereits für den haushalt
2023 mittel für den aktionsplan in
aussicht gestellt hat
das menschenrecht wohnbedarf unserer
gebündelten aufmerksamkeit ich danke
unseren bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier ausdrücklich dass er das
thema aufgegriffen hat mit seinen
engagement leistet er einen wichtigen
beitrag
wichtig ist was sich eingangs auch sagte
ein ambitioniertes wohnungsbauprogramm
wie wir es vorsehen wird sich am ende
auch daran messen lassen müssen ob es
uns gelungen ist wohnungslose
mitgenommen zu haben daran gemeinsam zu
arbeiten ist meine motivation
mit dem einzelplan und dem
bauministerium haben wir dafür den
grundstein gelegt nun lassen sie uns
gemeinsam das haus weiter bauen für alle
menschen in deutschland herzlichen dank
freynick holz das war der letzte redner
zu diesem einzelplan jetzt hören wir mal
die bundestags-vizepräsidentin petra pau
wir kommen zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan 25 bundesministerium für
wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen in
der ausschuss fassung wer stimmt dafür
landwehr stimmen dagegen
danke schön wer enthält sich der
einzelplan 25 ist mit den stimmen der
koalitionsfraktionen gegen die stimmen
der cdu csu fraktion der fdp fraktion
und der fraktion die linke angenommen
ja das war sozusagen der abschluss wenn
sie haushaltswoche nun schon mal
häufiger verfolgt haben dann wissen sie
bei den abschließen beratungen zum
bundeshaushalt
wir werden dann die einzelpläne in
zweiter lesung abgestimmt nach den
debatten das heißt hier wird die hand
gehoben beziehungsweise dann auch bei
den einstimmen die hand gehoben und erst
am freitag wenn das haushaltsgesetz 2022
mit dem finanzplan und den einzelplänen
gemeinsam abgestimmt wird dann gibt es
auch die dritte lesung wo dann
entsprechende aufgestanden wird ja der
einzelplan 25 der für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen das war ja
einer der etwas kleineren etats wenn man
das so sagen kann nach dem volumen nur
in anführungszeichen
4,96 milliarden euro das wichtigste der
größte einzelposten das baukindergeld
und das noch mal zu nennen mit knapp
einer milliarde auch das wohngeld mit
895 millionen ein großer posten und in
diesem post wohngeld erhalten sind
beispielsweise auch 100 30 millionen
euro als einmaliger zuschuss an die
wohngeldempfänger aufgrund der
gestiegenen heizkosten ja